process demandent du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Eric Dupont-Moretti garde des
sceaux ministres de la justice Vous AVEZ
LA PAROLE monsieur le ministre
bien monsieur le monsieur le président
le président de la commission des lois
madame la rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
Sénat examine aujourd'hui la proposition
de loi constitutionnelle
visant à protéger et à garantir le droit
fondamental à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse dans sa version adoptée en
première lecture par l'Assemblée
nationale le 24 novembre dernier
ce texte
n'est pas encore abouti
le rapport de la commission des Lois du
Sénat ne manque d'ailleurs pas de le
relever
mais il est le fruit d'un travail
constructif et transpartisans
entre les nombreux groupes politiques de
la chambre basse je veux ici d'ailleurs
saluer les présidentes bergers et
panneaux
depuis l'arrêt rendu le 24 juin 2022 par
la Cour suprême des États-Unis
6 propositions de loi constitutionnelles
ont été déposés sur les bureaux des
assemblées
6 propositions
si vision différente
et de beaux débats passés
présent
et à venir devant vos deux assemblées
l'importance des initiatives
parlementaires
dans cette matière démontre que le
revirement de jurisprudence de la Cour
suprême des États-Unis a eu l'effet chez
nous d'un électrochoc
nous devons être vigilants à ce que la
solidité de nos institutions se
maintiennent à l'épreuve du temps et que
ce droit
soit préservé
et quel droit
ce droit chermond conquis de chaque
femme a disposé de son corps
disons-le en la matière nous ne partons
pas de rien
et il ne faut pas mes estimer l'oeuvre
du Conseil constitutionnel
celui-ci depuis sa décision du 27 juin
reconnaître en effet que le droit à
l'IVG résulte
de la liberté de la femme qui découle de
l'article 2 de la Déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen
mais il s'agit à présent d'aller plus
loin
et de conférer un fondement
constitutionnel autonome à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
en l'érigeant explicitement au-delà de
la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel en liberté fondamentale
pour toutes ces raisons je persiste et
je signe le Gouvernement soutiendra
toutes les initiatives parlementaires
qui viseraient à constitutionnaliser le
droit à l'IVG
à ceux qui opposent à cette initiative
par le montant que le droit à
l'avortement n'est pas menacé en France
je réponds simplement ceci
n'attendons pas qu'il soit trop tard
pour le défendre le droit des femmes
disposer de leur corps
doit être inaliénable
en 1975
Simone Veil expliqué que l'objectif du
gouvernement était de créer je la cite
une loi réellement applicable
dissuasive
protectrice le législateur à travers de
nombreux textes successifs à atteint ses
objectifs mais l'objectif que nous
poursuivons aujourd'hui est autre il
s'agite à présent de protéger ce droit
en l'élevant au plus haut rang de la
hiérarchie des normes notre Constitution
ce faisant
nous donnerions avoir à toutes les
femmes toutes les femmes
qu'elles ont le choix
que celui-ci leur appartient et qu'elles
sont soutenues par la société tout
entière dans ce choix car oui les
exemples étrangers partout dans le monde
nous le démontre une démocratie digne de
ce nom ne peut exister sans l'émacie
sans l'émancipation totale de la moitié
de sa population
je tire votre attention sur la nécessité
de ne pas se tromper de débat
j'entends évidemment la commission des
lois lorsqu'elle pointe qu'une telle
inscription ne résoudrait pas les
difficultés concrètes d'accès à l'IVG
qui peuvent se rencontrer sur le terrain
le gouvernement est notamment mes
collègues Braun et Rome
gouvernement disait j'ai pleinement
engagé pour rendre ce droit le plus
effectif
concrètement sur le terrain mais il
s'agit là en réalité de deux sujets
différents
l'effectivité d'un droit d'une part et
sa protection juridique d'autre part
si les modalités d'exercice du droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
doivent pouvoir continuer à être
encadrés par le législateur car il
s'agit du niveau normatif le plus adapté
pour le faire le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse lui-même ne doit
pas être entravé restreint ou pire aboli
or une garantie constitutionnelle peut
nous assurer pour l'avenir
et ce pour une raison
notamment que j'avais évoqué devant vous
en octobre dernier
constitutionnaliser le droit à l'IVG
c'est s'assurer que ceux qui auraient se
naientfastes projet ne puisse le faire
sans l'accord du Sénat oui inscrire le
droit à l'IVG dans la Constitution c'est
garantir que le Sénat aura le dernier
mot pour protéger ce droit
comme il en a déjà protégé tant d'autres
dans la noble mission qui est la sienne
vous l'aurez compris tout comme la
commission gouvernement n'a pas changé
d'avis il est lui favorable à
l'inscription du droit à l'IVG dans
notre Constitution
j'en viens maintenant
à un sujet qui est sans doute le plus
complexe
comme mon témoigne les nombreuses
versions et amendement déposé dans les
deux chambres je veux bien sûr parler de
l'emplacement et de la rédaction
de cette inscription
je dis d'emblée il nous faut faire
montre de la plus grande humilité face à
ces deux questions nul ne détient la
vérité révélée et les propositions
méritent toutes d'être examinées pour
les avantages qu'elle contiennent aussi
bien que pour les réserves qu'elles
entraînent
l'emplacement de ce droit au sein de la
Constitution n'est pas une question
purement symbolique c'est avant tout une
question juridique
je l'ai déjà dit il ne faut toucher à
notre Constitution selon la formule
désormais consacrée que d'une main
tremblante la commission des lois
neciait d'ailleurs pas trompée
puisqu'elle a relevé qu'une telle
disposition devait trouver sa place dans
notre Constitution pour s'y fondre au
risque à défaut de la fragiliser le
choix de cet emplacement sera également
la traduction de la portée que le
Parlement a voulu lui assigner il
participera directement à donner tout
son sens à la reconnaissance de ce droit
à cet égard
monsieur le testeur bas propose un
amendement ayant pour objet outre de
proposer une rédaction alternative de
placer la reconnaissance de ce droit à
l'article 34 de la Constitution
je l'ai dit cette proposition comme les
précédentes méritent bien sûr un examen
attentif et sans déflorer les débats que
nous aurons dans quelques instants
et malgré le fait que Monsieur le Kuster
vous ayez comme à votre habitude peser
tous les mots au trébuchet
la rédaction que vous nous proposez
soulève plusieurs interrogations
elle renvoie en effet entièrement
au législateur le soin de déterminer les
conditions dans lesquelles les femmes
peuvent recourir à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse
c'est très exactement
l'état de notre droit
vous le savez
il résulte déjà de l'article 34 de la
Constitution qu'il revient au seul
législateur de prévoir les garanties
tout comme les limites du droit à
l'avortement
c'est ce qu'il a fait encore récemment
par la loi du 2 mars 2022
visant à renforcer le droit qu'à
l'avortement ce dont par ailleurs je me
réjouis j'entends votre argument
cette alinéa en faisant référence à
cette liberté qu'il revient à la loi
d'organiser
consacrerait implicitement cette liberté
au niveau constitutionnelle
le doute subsiste sur la réalité de cet
effet je comprends et partage par
ailleurs votre souci de laisser une
certaine marge de manoeuvre au
législateur il est en effet souhaitable
que les conditions dans lesquelles le
droit à l'avortement s'exerce puisse
évoluer avec le temps
l'Assemblée nationale a quant à elle
retenu la création d'un nouvel article
66-2 cet emplacement a été choisi par
les députés afin de donner une chance
supplémentaire au texte d'être voté par
le Sénat puisque vous aviez rejeté
quelques semaines plus tôt la
proposition de loi de la sénatrice Vogel
qui soutenait le même emplacement
le sujet reste donc ouvert sur ce point
en second lieu il y a évidemment la
question de la rédaction de cette
inscription du droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution là encore et à plus forte
raison il nous faut être humble face à
la tâche chaque mot doit bien évidemment
être réfléchie peser justifier et il ne
s'agit pas là d'une entreprise très
aisée après le refus net du Sénat de
constitutionnaliser le droit à la
contraception
l'Assemblée nationale a fait un premier
pas elle a ainsi renoncé par son vote à
l'inscription du droit à la
contraception dans la Constitution
recentrant ainsi la proposition sur la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
pour motiver son refus la commission des
lois à son tour à relever à bon droit
les risques d'une rédaction inaboutie
inadaptée les termes retenus
d'effectivité et d'égale accès semble
ainsi ouvrir mesdames et messieurs un
nouveau débat il est vrai comme je l'ai
indiqué devant l'Assemblée nationale
qu'une rédaction inadaptée pourrait
conduire à consacrer un accès sans
aucune condition
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
par exemple à des IVG réalisés bien
au-delà de la limite légale en vigueur
une écriture mal jaugée pourrait
également se révéler trop rigide et
empêcher une adaptation possible du
dispositif actuel si celle-ci était
nécessaire comme cela a été le cas en
mars dernier lors de l'adoption de la
loi du 2 mars 2022 visant à renforcer le
droit à l'avortement qui a allongé le
délai légal de recours à l'IVG de 12 à
14 semaines vous l'avez compris
la tâche est tordue mais la volonté est
claire le Parlement se mobilise comme
jamais auparavant pour consacrer le
droit à l'IVG dans la Constitution le
Gouvernement devant chaque assemblée est
venu soutenir les initiatives d'où
qu'elles émanent en participant au débat
dans le rôle qui naturellement et le
sien la navette parlementaire fait son
œuvre car je crois comprendre que
l'Assemblée nationale a pris acte du
premier refus du Sénat et vous présente
une version qui prend en compte un
certain nombre de craintes
comme je vous l'ai dit
toutes les craintes ne sont pas levées
car l'oeuvre est complexe mais l'espoir
est permis l'espoir que le Parlement
avec l'appui du gouvernement poursuivre
ses travaux pour trouver un accord il en
va du droit des femmes à disposer de
leur corps et cela seul devrait suffire
à nous convaincre tous
merci Monsieur le garder sceau la parole
est maintenant à Madame Agnès canaillier
rapporteur de la commission des lois
constitutionnelles pour 10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois mes chers collègues
ne faire ni plaisir ni tord mais faire
la loi c'est notre mandat notre
responsabilité de législateur et
d'élaborer une norme avec une certaine
hauteur retenue et maîtrise a fortiori
quand celle-ci tant à réviser la
Constitution
le 24 novembre dernier l'Assemblée
nationale a adopté un texte porté par la
présidente du groupe LFI visant de
nouveau inscrire dans la Constitution le
droit un interruption volontaire de
grossesse aujourd'hui il est soumis à
notre examen il introduit un nouvel
article 66.2 au sein du titre 8 consacré
à l'autorité judiciaire selon lequel la
loi garantit l'effectivité et légale
accès au droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse
la question n'est donc pas de savoir si
nous sommes pour ou contre l'IVG ne nous
laissons pas enfermer dans une lecture
simpliste binaire et parfois manichéenne
la véritable question qui nous est posée
est faut-il réviser la Constitution pour
y inscrire le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse faut-il modifier
la norme supérieure pour reconnaître la
liberté pour toute femme de mettre fin à
sa grossesse nous pensons que même si
l'opinion publique est forte cette idée
est une fausse bonne idée en effet si
les députés ont supprimé la référence à
la contraception cette évolution n'est
pas de nature à lever les doutes déjà
émis par le Sénat sur la pertinence de
la constitutionnalisation de droits à
l'IVG le 19 octobre dernier notre
Assemblée a rejeté une précédente
proposition de loi similaire présentée
par le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
la majorité sénatoriale avait déjà jugé
que la protection du droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
était très solide comme vous le savez
l'IVG est inscrit à l'article
2212-1 du code de la santé publique qui
dispose la femme enceinte qui ne veut
pas poursuivre une grossesse peut
demander un médecin ou à une sage-femme
l'interruption de sa grossesse la
liberté de la femme d'aborder est
aujourd'hui pleinement protégé par la
loi du 17 janvier 1975 porté par Simone
Veil qui fait aujourd'hui Patrick partie
intégrante de notre patrimoine juridique
et à laquelle le Sénat c'est toujours
montré fortement attaché l'accès à l'IVG
n'a jamais cessé d'être conforté par le
législateur allongement successifs des
délais élargissement des praticiens
pratiquant des IVG amélioration de la
prise en charge financière suppression
du critère de situation de détresse ou
encore du délai de réflexion préalable
certes le Conseil constitutionnel n'a
jamais consacré de droit constitutionnel
à l'avortement mais il a toujours jugé
conforme à la Constitution les quatre
fois où il s'est prononcé sur le sujet
en 1975 en 2001 en 2014 et en 2016 le
Conseil constitutionnel peut importe le
contexte ou l'époque n'a donc jamais
remis en question ce droit fondamental
des femmes depuis sa décision du 27 juin
2001 il rattache le droit à l'IVG au
principe général de la liberté de la
femme découlant de l'article 2 de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen de 789 qu'il concilie avec le
principe de sauvegarde de la dignité de
la personne humaine contre toute forme
de dégradation la jurance jurisprudence
établie du Conseil constitutionnel offre
d'ores et déjà une protection forte de
cette liberté de la femme alors
existe-t-il un réel danger de remise en
cause de l'IVG en France aucun groupe
politique n'a jamais indiqué vouloir
remettre en cause ce principe il est
donc pas crédible de soutenir que ce
droit est menacé en France de la même
manière qu'aux États-Unis ou dans
d'autres pays de l'Union européenne à
cet égard la situation institutionnelle
de la France n'étant rien qu'on
passerables à celle des États-Unis dire
le contraire c'est méconnaître la
réalité profonde de la décision de la
Cour suprême du 24 juin 2022 Dobbs
versus Jackson qui a renvoyé aux Etats
fédérés la compétence pour légiférer sur
la votre vortement en France la
situation est radicalement différente
notre République est une et indivisible
le législateur national dispose ainsi
d'une plénitude de compétences et les
lois sont les mêmes pour tous en
définitive le dispositif anti Trump
envisagé par cette proposition de loi de
révision constitutionnelle n'a pas lieu
d'être en France je préfère donc rester
fidèle aux conclusions rendues par le
comité présidé par Simone Veil en
décembre 2008 qui avait recommandé de ne
pas modifier le préambule ni dans la
constitution des dispositions de portée
purement symboliques car ce n'est pas un
symbole qui résoudra l'accès effectif à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
je m'indigne tout comme vous des
difficultés que rencontrent certaines
femmes pour interrompre leur grossesse
il est profondément inacceptable que des
femmes qui souhaitent recourir à l'IVG
ne puissent le faire dans de bonnes
conditions en particulier dans certains
territoires mais est-ce que la
constitutionnalisation résoudra ce
problème malheureusement non cette voie
est illusoire l'accès effectif à l'IVG
en France impose des moyens
supplémentaires pour le planning
familial impose l'accès à un médecin
dans tous les territoires impose le
développement des mesures de prévention
auprès des jeunes impose un ensemble de
mesures concrètes ces mesures sont
d'ordre réglementaires voire législatif
mais en aucun cas de nature
constitutionnelle il est clair par
ailleurs que la Constitution du 4
octobre 1958 n'a jamais été conçu pour
qu'il soit intégré toutes les
déclinaisons des droits et libertés
énoncées de manière générale dans son
préambule
pourquoi alors se limiter à l'IVG et ne
pas constitutionnaliser d'autres
manifestations de la liberté qui n'ont
pas non plus en tant que tel valeur
constitutionnelle pourquoi ne pas
inscrire dans le dur tous les droits et
libertés reconnus par le Conseil
constitutionnel pourquoi ne pas inscrire
demain tous les droits liés à la
bioéthique ou à la fin de vie parce que
la Constitution ne doit pas être un
catalogue de droit au contenu limité
enfin ce débat sur la
constitutionnalisation mes chers
collègues n'est pas aujourd'hui abouti
la proposition de loi constitutionnelle
dont nous débattons tout comme les
multiples initiatives législatives
soulève l'épineuse question de la
manière de réviser la Constitution la
difficulté de trouver une place
pertinente parmi les dispositions
constitutionnelles témoignent de
l'absence de cohérence de la proposition
de révision avec le texte de la
Constitution son intégration au sein du
titre 8 relatif à l'autorité judiciaire
juste après l'abolition de la peine de
mort
pas de croix surprendre les propositions
d'inscription à l'article 34 qui
détermine le domaine de la loi ou
l'article premier qualifié dame de la
Constitution par le doyen Carbonnier ne
sont pas plus satisfaisants cette
diversité démontre qu'il n'y a pas de
place naturelle pour inscrire ce droit
fondamental pour toute femme de mettre
fin dans sa grossesse dans la
Constitution en outre des lois que la
loi garantit l'effectivité les galaxies
aux droits à l'IVG cette formulation
laisse toujours entendre que son accès
pourrait être inconditionnel or le
législateur doit pouvoir fixer les
conditions comme pour toutes les
libertés publiques l'avortement ne peut
être un droit absolu sans limite enfin
je réitère les mêmes réserves de
procédures qu'en octobre dernier il
convient d'avoir un débat serein sur les
mérites d'une constitutionnalisation de
l'IVG si ceci était réellement démontré
l'introduction dans la Constitution
devrait suivre la voie d'un projet de
loi constitutionnel afin de mettre au
coeur de l'actualité par un référendum
un sujet pour lequel aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas de débat public pour toutes ces
raisons étant très attaché au droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
composant de la liberté de la femme je
vous invite à ne pas adopter cette
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
merci Madame la rapporteur nous passons
à la discussion de la motion pendant à
opposer la question préalable monsieur
Stéphane Ravier a déposé une motion
distribuée sous le numéro 2 tenda à
opposer la question préalable au texte
en discussion il a la parole pour 3
minutes vous avez la parole chers
collègues
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vous
présente cette émotion de rejet afin de
repousser à nouveau un texte inutile et
dangereux visant à constitutionnaliser
le droit à l'avortement je voudrais
d'abord citer les propos d'un rapport
concernant l'inflation normative remise
la semaine dernière par nos collègues
Françoise Gatel et Rémi pointeaux même
si le concert ne les normes applicables
aux collectivités territoriales le
propos peut tout à fait être élargi à
notre sujet en effet je les cite il y a
aujourd'hui une croyance quasi mystique
dans la norme miraculeuse qui
protégerait voir guérirait et d'ajouter
quand ils ne savent pas répondre à une
question qu'ils veulent répondre à une
émotion ou qu'il manque de moyens
financiers les pouvoirs publics cèdent
volontiers à la création de la norme
magique ces propos sur la qualité du
droit sont d'autant plus vraies quand il
s'agit de réviser la Constitution il
décrivent parfaitement bien l'exercice
de communication et d'agitation auquel
la majorité des députés s'est soumis et
que nous sommes sommets de poursuivre
dans notre
rassembler si tenter que cette révision
soit adoptée qu'aurait vous changer au
quotidien des formes de France rien
alors pourquoi s'opposer à ce texte me
direz-vous mes chers collègues parce que
son inutilité modifie l'esprit de la
Constitution l'État de droit se
transforme en tas de droit dès lors que
le pouvoir constituant s'introduit dans
la chambre à coucher les revendications
privées prennent le pas sur le bien
commun la reste plus qu'à cède le pas à
la race privata la République devient la
vie privée c'est-à-dire l'anarchie et la
fin de la société de plus en refusant de
rejeter ce texte de révision vous
multipliez les normes à valeur
constitutionnelle contradictoires et
renforcer les pouvoirs d'arbitrage des
juges au détriment du Parlement et donc
au détriment de la démocratie je me
permets de défendre ce point de vue
devant vous avec d'autant plus de
vigueur et d'honnêteté que je le fais
sans aucun intérêt électoral mais avec
le souci de l'intérêt général on ne joue
pas avec les textes juridiques sans
consé sources politiques la loi veille à
dépénaliser l'avortement il y a 48 ans
vous souhaitez aujourd'hui
en travestir l'esprit en l'établissant
comme un objectif de société
contrairement à ce que vous affirmez
l'avortement n'est pas menacé en France
il sait même renforcé le pays ne s'est
pas mis en grève générale hier pour
l'interdire en revanche la natalité elle
est réellement menacée au plus bas
depuis la prière la vitalité de notre
pays la main d'oeuvre des métiers en
tension les cotisants du système de
répartition des retraites se cache
évidemment dans les 10 millions
d'avortement depuis 48 ans l'air des
conséquences est venue sachant en tirer
les enseignements avec le sens des
responsabilités je vous propose donc mes
chers collègues de couper court à cette
instrumentalisation de la Constitution
en rejetant dès à présent ce texte
inconséquent et idéologique présenté
dois-je le rappeler par la France
insoumise
merci chers collègues
orateur contre inscrits contre la motion
sur yakovelli vous avez la parole pour
trois minutes également
merci monsieur le Président je vous
rassure je ferai pas 3 minutes monsieur
le garder ce mes chers collègues nous
voterons évidemment contre cette
question préalable comme le disait
Victor Hugo bien connu dans ses murs la
forme c'est le fond qui remonte à la
surface et votre prise de parole
monsieur le sénateur ravier c'est une
contribution à votre corps défendu bien
sûr une en faveur de renforcement à
droit à l'IVG et c'est ce qui est
proposé ici je relisais votre
intervention d'octobre dernier sur une
même procédure visant une même démarche
législative transpartizane initié par
notre collègue Mélanie vosgel au début
on pourrait croire que il s'agit d'une
prise de position sur la
non-constitutionnalisation du droit
l'IVG mais on s'interroge alors pourquoi
refuser d'en discuter par le dépôt d'une
question préalable je crois pour ma part
qu'il est important d'inscrire ce droit
à l'IVG dans la Constitution car cela a
été rappelé notamment par le garde des
sceaux il est beaucoup plus difficile de
modifier la Constitution que de changer
la loi qu'une autre majorité peut
défaire en quelques mois
alors on peut avoir des avis divergents
sur les moyens de renforcer ce droit
mais pourquoi on en discuterait pas
pourquoi refuser par cette question
préalable le débat
et puis c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure le c'est à ce moment-là que le
fond remonte à la surface monsieur le
sénateur vous en arrivez au fait une
attaque à la vie je vous cite une
contribution à l'hiver démocratique et
j'en passe aucun pays n'est jamais à
l'abri d'une majorité politique avec les
idées que vous défendez
les Français nous en préservent
susceptibles d'abroger les dispositions
autorisant l'avortement la contraception
et d'en restreindre considérablement
l'accès alors je veux conclure chers
collègues en salon ici tous ceux sur
tous nos bancs de gauche de droite du
Centre qui se sont battus depuis des
décennies pour protéger ce droit pour le
renforcer pour que les femmes ait ce
droit à disposer de leur corps sur cela
mes chers collègues nous serons toujours
ensemble toujours ensemble face à
l'extrême droite et c'est pour cette
raison que vous je vous appelle à
rejeter cette question préalable
merci
quelle est l'avis de la commission sur
la question préalable madame la
rapporteur oui merci monsieur le
président la commission des lois est mis
un avis défavorable sur cette question
préalable effectivement c'est un débat
de fond c'est un débat d'importance qui
concerne notre norme suprême la
Constitution il y a des divergences il
faut que toutes les idées s'expriment il
faut que toutes les convictions puissent
au sein de cette hémicycle être entendu
c'est pour ça que nous pensons que ce
débat est d'importance et qu'il doit
être mené à son terme et qu'en aucun cas
nous devons l'évacuer grâce à cette
question préalable c'est pour cela que
nous émettons un avis défavorable
si la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
garde des sceaux
très rapide monsieur le Président
tout le monde peut apprécier la nuance
avec laquelle s'exprime le sénateur
ravier c'est même ça marque de fabrique
d'une certaine façon pour autant c'est
un débat sociétal qui est extrêmement
important
j'ai une petite divergence avec vous
Madame la rapporteur vous dites le droit
à l'avortement n'est pas menacé dans
notre pays
mais aux États-Unis quand ces règles ont
été mises en place permettant aux femmes
d'avorter personne ne pouvait imaginer
qu'un jour
il y aurait des amis de Monsieur Trump
qui viendrait remettre ce droit
fondamental en cause et au fond
constitutionnaliser ce droit c'est
assurer l'avenir bien sûr que la menace
n'est pas immédiate à part
quelques-uns qui pas très favorable au
fond et qu'il exprime par prétérition
vous savez la prétérition aux yeux de
sénateur ravier dire les choses sans les
dire tout en les disant puis
là franchement c'est digne de l'almana
Vermot l'État de droit et l'état de
droit oui on sait ce que vous pensez de
l'État de droit on sait vous l'exprimer
en permanence puis je dois encore vous
dire une dernière chose là-dessus je
dois encore vous dire une toute dernière
chose là-dessus votre votre compagnon de
route le dernier pas l'avant-dernière le
dernier il est favorable à une mise au
pas du Conseil constitutionnel c'est
clair il l'a dit il l'a exprimé durant
la campagne présidentielle de façon tout
à fait claire c'est l'état
de droit et puis une dernière chose en
Hongrie vous savez ce que l'on vient de
faire et de mettre en place pour les
femmes qui souhaitent avorter on les
contraint à attendre en entendre
pardonnez-moi les battements de cœur du
fœtus qu'elle porte en elle c'est une
c'est une torture psychologique ce sont
vos amis
acceptés accepter l'augure et l'idée que
je vous le rappelle ce sont vos amis
monsieur Orban et votre ami voilà
et ben voilà vous voyez donc il y a non
pas péril en la demeure madame la
rapporteur non mais on sait jamais au
fond et puis il vaut mieux que ce droit
soit inscrit dans la Constitution c'est
un merveilleux message que l'on adresse
à l'ensemble des femmes voilà monsieur
le sénateur ravier
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre après cette
déclaration extrêmement intéressante je
demande un avis j'aurais aimé vous
entendre dire à vie défavorable donc
vous reprenez le micro vous dites avis
défavorable
d'abord je constate que vous aviez
compris que c'était des favorable
monsieur le Président merci
favorable merci
merci allez on va rester calme si on
veut aller au bout du doigt je vous
rappelle juste moi c'est pas un problème
que c'est une niche ce qui veut dire
qu'à 20h45 si du fait des débats on n'a
pas voté c'est suspendu et renvoyé à la
prochaine mise dans plusieurs semaines
donc tout le monde a intérêt à faire en
sorte qu'on arrive au vote quoi je dis
ça allez je vais consulter le Sénat sur
la motion tendance à opposer la question
préalable je rappelle que l'adoption de
cette motion entraînerait le rejet du
texte en discussion en application de
l'article 59 du règlement le scrutin
public et de droit
le scrutin
est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
345 exprimé 345 pour une voix contre 344
la motion sur la question préalable
n'est pas adoptée et nous abordons la
discussion générale
la parole
chers collègues merci d'écouter chacun
des orateurs la première oratrice et
Madame Esther benbasa pour le groupe des
non inscrits pour 3 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le texte
dont nous débattons aujourd'hui a été
rejeté en commission mercredi dernier
trois jours après l'organisation d'une
manifestation pour la vie à Paris rien
de nouveau sous le soleil sénatorial un
texte similaire avait été déjà rejeté en
octobre dernier si le recours à
l'avortement est protégé chez nous par
la loi veille du 17 janvier
1975 il ne bénéficie pas pour autant
aujourd'hui de la protection la plus
forte qui soit dans nos droits
sanctuariser en le faisant entrer dans
la Constitution ce droit fondamental de
la femme à disposer de son corps qui le
mettrait à l'abri des tempêtes
politiques
souvenons-nous de ce qui s'est passé
dans des pays de l'Est de l'Europe comme
la Pologne et la Hongrie et même dans
une grande démocratie comme les
États-Unis sous la pression des
conservateurs l'Italie risque à son tour
de s'engager dans cette voie de la
régression notre collègue Philippa a
proposé une nouvelle rédaction de la
formule retenue par l'Assemblée
nationale en substituant à la notion de
droit d'accès à l'IVG celle de la
liberté de mettre fin à sa grossesse une
liberté déjà reconnue selon lui par la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel du
27 juin 2001
quoi de neuf dans ce cas d'autant que
liberté n'est pas droit
or le recours à l'IVG doit être traité
comme un droit effectif ainsi que le
préconisé un rapport de 2020 réalisé par
la délégation droit des femmes de
l'Assemblée nationale jusqu'à quand
devons-nous nous battre pour une
reconnaissance pleine et entière du
droit des femmes à disposer de leur
corps à choisir leur maternité les
hommes choisissent bien leur paternité
et jouissent du droit de reconnaître ou
non leur enfant pourquoi vouloir
toujours ouvertement ou indirectement
contrôler la sexualité des femmes
si cette navette échouée au Sénat il
serait opportun que l'exécutif se
saisisse de la PPLC avec courage pour en
faire un projet de loi de surcroître
seul ce véhicule législatif permettrait
d'éviter la case référendum très
périlleuse dans le contexte politique
actuel
au cas où les deux chambres se mettrai
d'accord sur un texte en moins bien sûr
que le but inavoué de l'exécutif soit de
faire traîner les choses ou de les
rendre difficiles j'espère que non merci
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à monsieur Jean-Yves roux
pour le groupe RDSE pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur mes chers
collègues chacun en tête le volte-face
historique de la Cour suprême américaine
qui est venue rappeler combien l'accès à
l'avortement demeure un droit très
inégal et fragile dans le monde nous
retrouvons donc aujourd'hui un texte que
notre assemblée avait hélas que jeté au
mois d'octobre dernier tant mieux qu'il
revienne même si ce n'est que dans une
version plus épurée peut-on dire
puisqu'il n'est plus question de
contraception mais seulement de l'IVG
pour autant même avec cette réécriture
je regrette que le texte n'est pas été
amélioré d'un point de vue plus formel
un tel sujet aurait pu ne pas être
pollué par des questions de formalisme
juridique car si nous sommes attachés à
la défense de l'IVG comme liberté pour
les femmes pour les hommes qui les
accompagnent nous sommes également
attachés à notre Constitution comme
texte fondamental et précieux chacun
connaît ici la formule de Montesquieu on
le touche à la constitution que d'une
main tremblante de tout évidente le
choix de placer cette disposition dans
un chapitre dédié à l'autorité
judiciaire ne serait convenir l'article
34 aurait réparé plus opportun en tout
cas moins inapproprié j'ai également
entendu certains arguments qui ne m'ont
pas convaincus dire que nous sommes en
France et pas aux États-Unis pour nier
la tendance mondiale et européenne à une
forme de recul des droits et des
libertés fondamentales des femmes au
contraire je dirais même que si d'autres
reculent soyons faire fiers de montrer
le chemin inverse le chemin qui refuse
la régression ensuite on avance que la
constitutionnalisation est illusoire
parce qu'elle ne résoudrait pas les
problèmes d'accès à l'IVG evidemment
mais à quoi faudrait-il s'attendre une
telle remarque vaut finalement pour
absolument tous les droits consacrés par
le bloc de constitutionnalité pensons
par exemple aux libertés de conscience
de réunion d'expression de presse
chacune a été consacrée sans que la
consécration ne révolte à elle seule la
question de leur accès les problèmes
d'accès et de réalisation concrète de
son gouvernement pas des problèmes
constitutionnels c'est tous les
utilisateur et au pouvoir réglementaire
de les régler notre Constitution doit
afficher des principes des valeurs et
des objectifs elle montre la finalité de
notre droit celle-là laquelle il ne peut
déroger de toute évidence la garantie de
la liberté des femmes d'interables en
grossesse tout vous sa place dans un tel
corpus et il me semble trop précaire de
se limiter à la seule interprétation
juridictionnelle du Conseil
constitutionnel pour reprendre les mots
de notre collègue c'est faire larzano un
revirement de jurisprudence et
d'interprétation serait trop simple à se
justifier or nous expliquerait que
l'article 2 de la Déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen et sur lequel
le Conseil appuie sa jurisprudence ne
serait faire au sens strict ou
historique ni à l'IVG ni à la
contraception cette offense qui est
arrivé aux États-Unis et ce dont nous
allons nous prévaloirs bref tout cela
expliquera pourquoi notre groupe dans sa
majorité votera en faveur de cette
proposition de loi constitutionnelle je
vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant Monsieur
Philippe Bas pour le groupe les
républicains pour 5 minutes
monsieur le garde des sceaux monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
madame la rapporteur permettez-moi tout
d'abord de saluer l'extrême
pertinence et la vigueur de la
présentation du rapport par Madame Agnès
canaillé elle justifie amplement notre
refus de voter cette proposition de loi
je reprendrai seulement quelques-uns des
arguments qu'elle a énoncé en
m'attachant au texte de cette
proposition je ne m'attarderai pas sur
le fait qu'elle n'est pas rédigée en
français j'ai cru constater que ça
n'était qu'un détail qu'on peut faire
des fautes de grammaire dans la
Constitution sans que personne
en revanche en revanche
je veux dire que
cette rédaction ne bénéfique ne définit
pas ce qu'est le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse le présente
comme un absolu une sorte de créance sur
la société et ne prévoit de garantie par
le législateur que pour l'effectivité
qui relève plutôt de l'organisation du
système de santé et pour les galaxies
qui est naturellement une mesure sociale
tout à fait estimable mais qui n'est pas
au cœur du débat
ce qui est au cœur du débat en revanche
c'est la substance de ce droit
indéfini à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse que les auteurs de cette
proposition
prétendent de voir reconnaître comme le
garde des sceaux la suggérer dans son
intervention
l'idée que ce droit serait illimité et
le mettrait à part de toutes les autres
libertés constitutionnelles n'est pas
exclu par la rédaction qui a été adopté
et il me semble que on ne peut
reconnaître un droit à une liberté sans
en prévoir aussi les conditions
c'est-à-dire les limites et c'est ce qui
fait précisément l'équilibre de la loi
veille
jusqu'à l'achèvement d'un certain délai
c'est la liberté de la femme qui prévaut
après l'achèvement de ce délai c'est la
protection de l'enfant à naître dont je
m'étonne que personne n'est parlé et
bien cette équilibre fondamental c'est
celui qui précisément a fait accepter la
loi veille par la société française
depuis près de 50 ans et qui justifie
aujourd'hui qu'il y ait une forme de
consensus autour du droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
tel qu'il a été défini par la loi veille
même si elle a évolué au cours du temps
par un certain nombre de réformes alors
la question qui se pose à nous c'est
est-ce que il est pertinent d'inscrire
une liberté ou un droit dans la
Constitution je réponds que c'est déjà
le cas l'article premier prévoit
l'égalité devant la loi l'article
premier prévoit le respect de toutes les
croyances on y a ajouté les libertés
locales avec l'organisation
décentralisée de la République les
galaxies des femmes et des hommes aux
fonctions électives on a décidé aussi
que nul ne peut être condamné à la peine
de mort c'est donc bien un lieu qui
permet d'accueillir des libertés que le
pouvoir constituant qui est souverain
est auquel on peut assigner aucune
limite veut voir consacrer
je propose une contre-proposition au
texte qui nous est soumis et cette
contre proposition elle vise à garantir
l'équilibre de la loi veille elle
reprend
l'énoncé d'une liberté qui a été
reconnue par le Conseil constitutionnel
dans sa décision du 27 juin 2001 et elle
se dit cette liberté mais elle prévoit
aussi que les législateur en détermine
les conditions et donc les limites comme
la prévue la loi vert et je crois qu'on
ne peut pas sortir de cette équation il
n'y a pas de droit absolu il y a une
liberté déjà reconnue et que nous
pouvons écrire dans la Constitution mais
à la condition qu'il y ait une
conciliation entre les droits de la
femme enceinte de mettre fin à sa
grossesse et la protection de l'enfant à
naître après un certain délai voilà
monsieur le Président ce que je voulais
vous dire monsieur le garde des sceaux
vous avez dit tout à l'heure rappelant
une formule célèbre qu'il ne fallait
toucher à la constitution que d'une main
tremblante les vôtres sont restés dans
vos poches
et il me semble et il me semble qu'on
aurait tout de même intérêt puisque vous
critiquez un certain nombre de rédaction
avoir celles que le gouvernement
pourrait nous soumettre après à vie du
Conseil d'État pour engager un processus
qui aurait de meilleures chances
d'aboutir vous restez sur le banc de
touche libre à vous c'est un confort que
nous ne voulons pas vous donner
durablement car le verrou du Sénat peut
être levé et vous serez alors mis face à
vos responsabilités
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Colette mélo pour le
groupe les indépendants pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
Président de la Commission mes chers
collègues le texte que nous examinons a
été adopté à l'Assemblée nationale à une
très large majorité il vise à faire de
l'IVG un droit constitutionnel sa
rédaction était initialement
identique à celle du texte rejetée par
notre chambre en octobre dernier elle a
été modifiée par les députés lors de son
examen en séance publique pour favoriser
son adoption notre groupe considère que
toute femme doit avoir la possibilité
d'interrompre sa grossesse lorsqu'elle
le décide dans le cadre du régime établi
par la loi ce régime comme bien d'autres
et le fruit d'un équilibre délicat entre
la liberté de la mer d'une part et la
sauvegarde de la dignité de la personne
humaine d'autre part
certaines évolutions législatives
étrangères font craindre en recul des
libertés un revirement de jurisprudence
de la Cour suprême américaine a ainsi
rendu aux Etats le droit d'interdire ou
d'autoriser l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse il s'agit d'un retour en
arrière manifeste plus proche de nous
législation a été durci en Pologne et en
Hongrie réduisant fortement l'accès à
l'IVG il reste d'ailleurs interdit à
Malte les reculs de cette liberté se
traduisent par des poursuites pénales
tant pour la mère que pour le médecin
comme nos concitoyens ces évolutions
nous inquiète dans notre pays
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
n'est pas aujourd'hui menacée
politiquement les délais ont ainsi
récemment été allongés de 12 à 14
semaines aucun parti politique de l'arc
républicain ne plaide pour la remise en
cause de l'IVG cependant ce qui menace
l'IVG c'est bien davantage le manque de
moyens le manque de qui transforme
certaines intervention en parcours de la
combattante le gouvernement s'est dit
favorable à la constitutionnalisation de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
si cette proposition venait à être votée
en terminantique il faudrait encore la
soumettre à un référendum pour que la
Constitution soit modifiée nous avons
cru comprendre qu'il y a quelques
réticences à mener un tel référendum y
compris d'ailleurs parmi les auteurs de
la proposition de loi dans ces
conditions il sera difficile d'expliquer
pourquoi l'Assemblée nationale et le
Sénat ont débattu longuement et à
plusieurs reprises d'une
constitutionnalisation tant que ces
débats sans que ces débats n'étant rien
amélioré l'accès de nos concitoyennes à
l'IVG nous l'avons dit notre groupe est
très attaché au Liberté individuelles et
notamment à celle d'interrompre une
grossesse nous souhaitons également que
nos concitoyennes bénéficient d'avancer
concrète à cet égard il me semble
nécessaire de densifier l'offre de soins
sur notre territoire la problématique
des déserts médicaux est bien connu de
notre assemblée elle a de graves
conséquences et notamment en matière
d'IVG il conviendrait également
d'améliorer la compagnement des femmes
décidant d'avorter tout au long de leur
parcours notamment quant à la gestion
des délais trop de femmes sont encore
aux contraintes de se rendre à
l'étranger pour avorter que ces femmes
soient mineures ou non quelles étaient
victimes d'agression ou non
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
est toujours une épreuve il est de notre
devoir d'accompagner au mieux les femmes
qui ont recours les membres de notre
groupe Les Indépendants Républiques et
territoires sont unanimement favorables
à la liberté d'avorter certains
s'interrogent sur l'intérêt de son
inscription dans la Constitution chacun
votera donc selon ses convictions en ce
qui me concerne je ne prendrai pas par
au vote car les termes de la votre
veille me paraissent suffisamment
équilibrée
pierre collègue la parole est maintenant
madame Mélanie Vogel pour le groupe
écologiste pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre sur collègue donc nous
prononçons aujourd'hui encore sur
l'introduction du droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution je souhaitais d'abord
saluer le travail de l'Assemblée
nationale ce vote qui a rendu si fier
des Françaises et les Français et le
sens de l'intérêt général qui a été
celui de Mathilde panot d'Aurore berger
et de toutes celles et ceux qui à gauche
comme à droite on suit se rassembler
autour d'un impératif bien plus grand
que nos désaccords politiques la loi
veille que tant d'évoquer ici et
évoqueront je suis sûr aujourd'hui la
loi veille est donc le point de départ
de l'accès des phases au droit à
l'avortement en France a nécessité comme
tant d'autres victoires politiques la
réunion de trois éléments la
mobilisation des féministes d'abord et
comme toujours des féministes qui des
années durant et depuis des décennies
ont battu le pavé mais leur vie en
danger pour sauver tant d'autres de
l'horreur et pour imposer la
reconnaissance du dieu le plus
fondamental celui que nous avons à
disposer de nos corps à contrôler notre
fécondité et plus largement à maîtriser
nos vies
la détermination et la responsabilité de
la gauche ensuite d'une gauche qui a su
à un moment donné de l'histoire et quand
bien même la loi Veil était loin bien
loin de notre idéal rendre l'imparfaite
mais nécessaire victoire possible et
enfin et c'est de cela et profondément
de cela au fond dont il est question
aujourd'hui de la dignité d'une partie
de la droite une certaine partie de la
droite qui en dépit des pressions du
conservatisme de l'idéologie violemment
sexiste et misogyne qui pétrissait alors
une bonne partie de ses rangs c'est
allié à un combat dont aucune digne
représentant de la nation ne pouvait
persister à freiner l'aboutissement nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une situation
foncièrement similaire parce qu'elle est
tant attachée à ce qui constitue l'une
des conditions les plus fondamentales de
les galaxies à la citoyenneté 86% de la
population française souhaite voir le
droit à l'IVG entrer dans la
Constitution dans ces 86% se trouvent
tant de vos filles de vos petites filles
et de leurs amis
toutes celles et ceux qui savent dans
leur chair qui n'est jamais quand il est
question d'IVG de protection superflue
et qu'il vaut toujours mieux trembler
d'une main pour protéger des droits que
se tétanisé pour refuser de le faire pas
pour le symbole ni pour l'esthétique
mais par la responsabilité immense que
nous confère la conscience aiguë que
nous avons des menaces qui planent
toujours sur les droits des femmes et de
la force de ce message d'espérance que
la France peut aujourd'hui envoyer au
monde entier car si la France n'est pas
un pays magique protégé de la marge du
monde immunisée contre les reculs elle
est aujourd'hui un pays tout particulier
un pays que pas seulement les
américaines mais les Polonaises les
maltaises les Hongroises les Allemandes
les Italiens les Iraniennes les
chiliennes regardent parce que ce pays
peut aujourd'hui dans cette période si
sombre pour les droits des femmes tracés
enfin un chemin d'espoir et de progrès
je ne sais pas chers collègues
combien d'entre vous aujourd'hui
choisiront quel camp mais je sais
profondément une chose comme je crois
intimement beaucoup ici le savent ceux
qui voteront aujourd'hui en faveur de
l'inscription du droit à l'avortement
dans la Constitution n'auront jamais
jamais honte de leur vote notamment
quand viendra le jour où le Conseil
constitutionnel
censura une loi attaquant le droit à
l'IVG et que les autres
auront tout le mal du monde à expliquer
à leur petite fille qu'ils auront tout
fait pour œuvrer à les protéger en ce
qui nous concerne parce que dans les
moments de bascule de l'histoire nous
serons toujours à notre responsabilité
nous sommes prêtes et prêts à voter un
texte qui même s'il venait à l'issue du
débat à ne pas pleinement nous
satisfaire permettrait de poursuivre
l'avancée de notre pays vers cette
grande victoire protéger un droit avant
qu'il soit menacé évidemment quand ils
le sera il sera trop tard pour agir je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Xavier yakovelli
pour le groupe RDPI pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le garder
ce mes chers collègues le 19 octobre
dernier le sauna rejetait la proposition
de loi constitutionnelle de notre
collègue Mélanie vosgel visant à
protéger et à garantir le droit
fondamental à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse et à la contraception outre
les arguments avancés lors de ces débats
je ne reviendrai pas dessus nous
retiendrons que ce vote fut le signal
malheureux envoyé à nos concitoyens et
particulièrement aux femmes
ne soyons pas aveugle de leur demande
ils nous regardent
aujourd'hui le droit à l'IVG est remis
en cause dans le monde c'est un fait
depuis l'animation de la raie rohen
versus Wade très État américain ont
rendu illégal l'avortement et 5 en ont
limité l'accès et cela en moins d'un an
au sein même de l'Union européenne les
menaces qui pèsent sur ce droit sont
visibles je prends l'exemple pris tout à
l'heure par le garde des sceaux sur la
Hongrie où on oblige maintenant les
femmes avant d'avorter à écouter le cœur
du fœtus
il est donc légitime de s'interroger sur
son avenir en France à l'image de la
Marche pour la vie du 22 janvier dernier
ou encore le récent colloque anti IVG
parrainé par notre collègue malheureux
sénateur ravier les militants
anti-avortement constituent et
continuent d'utiliser tous les moyens
possibles pour diffuser leur idéologie
rétrograde et pernicieuse vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le garder sceau un
droit n'est jamais acquis l'histoire
nous le prouve et je pourrais ajouter
que ce n'est encore moins acquis lorsque
c'est un droit pour les femmes ou un
droit pour les enfants
et malgré cela en dépit des solides
arguments avancés nous n'avons pas
réussi à obtenir une majorité en
première lecture pour protéger et
garantir le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse en inscrivant
dans notre Constitution qu'avons-nous
qu'attendons-nous mes chers collègues
pour le faire nous nous trompons pas de
débat il ne s'agit pas ici d'empêcher un
retour en arrière qui suscite la crainte
d'abandon de nos concitoyens nous avons
de nouveau l'occasion de voter en ce
sens saisissons là
en constitutionnalisant le droit à l'IVG
notre pays ferait preuve et œuvres de
pionniers dans la matière
ne sous-estimons pas la puissante portée
symbolique d'un tel acte vis-à-vis de
l'Occident
fidèle à sa vocation universaliste il
enverrait un message fort au pays où le
droit à l'avortement est bafoué ou
inexistant la France défend
virogoureusement sur la scène
internationale les droits des femmes
alors allons plus loin je tiens à saluer
le sénateur bas qui dans un esprit
constructif propose de réécrire
l'article unique dans le prolongement de
la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel bien que son amendement
prévoit que la loi détermine les
conditions dans lesquelles s'exerce la
liberté de la femme de mettre fin à sa
grossesse il ne consacre pas pour autant
le droit l'IVG comme un droit autonome
pour aller plus loin mes chers collègues
j'ai donc déposé un sous-amendement dont
l'adoption constituerait selon moi une
avancée significative en termes de
rédaction notamment en faisant
apparaître les notions d'effectivité et
de libre accès à ce droit
rien ne s'oppose au rehaussement du
niveau de protection du droit à l'IVG la
Constitution par référence au préalable
de 1789 et de 1946 ainsi qu'aux articles
premiers et 66-1 reconnaît déjà une
série de droits et de liberté
fondamentaux
contrairement à ce que vous affirmez
madame la rapporteur inscrire dans notre
loi fondamentale un droit garantit
depuis près de 50 ans ne semble pas
constituer je vous cite un changement de
nature de la Constitution d'hommageable
nous sommes nombreux dans cette émission
à considérer que la
constitutionnalisation du droit à l'IVG
serait parfaitement compatible avec
notre tradition juridique c'est pourquoi
une larve de majorité du groupe RDPI
soutiendra ce texte au nom du droit des
femmes au nom de leur droit à disposer
de leur corps et tout simplement au nom
de leur liberté
[Applaudissements]
merci
la parole est maintenant madame
Marie-Pierre delagonie pour le groupe
socialiste pour 6 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux madame la rapporteur mes
chers collègues
n'oubliez jamais
il suffira d'une crise politique
économique religieuse pour que les
droits des femmes nos droits soient
remis en question votre vie durant vous
devrez rester vigilante voilà ce que
déclarait Simone de Beauvoir il y a un
demi-siècle
rappelons-nous le long chemin la lutte a
prépa foi violente que les femmes ont
mené pour obtenir par la première loi
veille du 17 janvier 75 la
dépénalisation de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse n'oublions pas
toutes ces femmes criminalisées pour
avoir avorté ou pouvoir pour avoir aidé
d'autres à le faire n'oublions pas
toutes celles qui sont mortes faute
d'avoir eu accès à des conditions dignes
pour pratiquer un avortement
la constitutionnalisation de l'IVG dont
nous parlons aujourd'hui s'inscrit dans
cette longue histoire de la lutte des
femmes pour leurs droits parce que ça a
été rappelé notre Constitution et la
règle la plus élevée de l'ordre
juridique elle organise notre vie
institutionnelle mais elle indique aussi
nos valeurs nos principes qui fondent
notre communauté elle traduit notre
contrat social le Comité des droits
économiques socio-éculturels des Nations
Unies a écrit que l'égalité de genre
impose de tenir compte des besoins de
santé des femmes qui diffèrent de ceux
des hommes si ce principe avait été
connu des rédacteurs du Préambule de la
Constitution de 46 son article 3 qui
garantit aux femmes des droits égaux à
ceux des hommes auraient consacré la
liberté reproductive spécifique des
femmes
cette liberté reproductive des femmes et
la condition de l'égalité entre les
sexes et doit figurer au sein du texte
qui fonde notre communauté en tant que
condition pour cette égalité ce serait
en France notre fierté et notre honneur
d'être le premier pays au monde inscrire
dans la Constitution le droit des femmes
à disposer de leur corps
ce combat il est mené par la gauche
depuis longtemps il est aujourd'hui
partagé par plus de 80% des Français qui
sont favorables toutes conviction
politique confondue toute conviction
religieuse confondue pourtant certains
pensent qu'il serait inutile de protéger
le droit d'IVG au motif que la
législation actuelle le protégerait
suffisamment cela a été dit tout à
l'heure par le garde des sceaux ne
sera-t-il pas à leur trop tard pour
légiférer si des forces rétrograde
prennent le pouvoir et décide de
s'attaquer à ce droit
m'avez-vous pas vu les manifestations
hostiles au droit à l'avortement qui se
sont tenus au cours des derniers mois
notamment dans les rues de Paris il y a
quelques jours rassemblant plusieurs
milliers de personnes d'autres affirment
que le droit à l'IVG serait déjà garanti
constitutionnellement au titre des
libertés fondamentales cela résultent
selon nous d'une incompréhension si le
Conseil constitutionnel n'a pas conclu à
une inconstitutionnalité depuis sa
décision initiale sur la loi veille de
75 puis pour chacune de ces
modifications législatives il n'a
cependant jamais formellement reconnu
l'IVG comme un droit fondamental ces
lois à l'époque ont été validées au
motifs qu'elle respectait un équilibre
entre d'une part la sauvegarde de la
dignité de la personne humaine contre
toute forme de dégradation et d'autre
part la liberté de la femme qui découle
de l'article 2 de la Déclaration de 1789
mais sans conférer pour autant une
protection autonome au droit à l'IVG et
réponse là que nous nous battons pour
cette constitutionnalisation qui
procurerait évidemment une protection
beaucoup plus forte à ce droit certains
avancent que cela ne résoutrait
cependant pas d'effectivité de son accès
sur l'ensemble du territoire c'est
pourquoi notre texte initial le prévoir
mais pourquoi opposer
constitutionnalisation d'IVG et la
question de son accès ne peut-on à la
fois améliorer l'accès à l'IVG sur
l'ensemble de notre territoire et donner
une protection supplémentaire à ce droit
en le constitutionnalisant d'autres
qualifient d'inutiles cette
constitutionnalisation au motif qui
n'existerait aucun aucun risque de
remise en cause dans notre pays et
pourtant nous le voyons ce mouvement
nous le voyons en Europe nous le voyons
aux États-Unis et dire cela ces pensées
que la France notre pays serait une
sorte d'Ilo protecteur et protégé dans
une Europe et un monde qui vacille sur
l'ensemble de ses droits
d'autres sur ce même raisonnement aurait
dû s'opposer à la constitutionnalisation
de l'abolition de la peine de mort
puisque vous le savez les engagements
internationaux de la France permettait
de toute façon ce retour en arrière
impossible un mot enfin de la
proposition de notre collègue Philippe
Bas qui s'engage dans cette
constitutionnalisation avec une
rédaction différente qui nous a
détailler précédemment
elle présente selon nous de faiblesses
la première évidence elle n'est pas
conforme au dispositif retenu par
l'Assemblée nationale et donc ne permet
pas à ce stade de votre conforme mais
plus encore
elle choisit d'utiliser le terme de
liberté et non pas le terme de droit or
je le dis au président BA et je le dis à
vous tous l'IVG n'est pas seulement une
liberté pour nous c'est un droit mais
cette rédaction proposée à la vertu de
s'engager sur le chemin de la
constitutionnalisation et au fond
rappelons-nous que la première loi
veille n'a pu être adoptée que grâce à
un travail transpartisan et à la
participation des groupes parlementaires
de la gauche qui avait accepté de larges
concession alors prenons cette démarche
comme un appel au consensus et à la
construction transpartisane lancée par
Philippe Bas notre groupe la soutiendra
comme étant positive même si elle est
imparfaite et puis monsieur le ministre
je reprendrai à mon compte les propos de
Philippe Bas vous avez fait état d'une
analyse très fournie très intéressante
mais nous avons envie de vous voir
concrétiser cette analyse dans une
rédaction qui serait celle du
gouvernement
nous donne rendez-vous pour cela ce soir
je le dis de manière solennelle le Sénat
a rendez-vous avec son histoire avec
l'histoire du droit des femmes elle
l'attend et ne les décevait pas
[Applaudissements]
la parole et maintenant
à Madame Laurence Cohen pour le groupe
CRCE pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
gardeesseau mes chers collègues Gisèle à
la limite affirmait déjà en 1973 il y a
dans le droit d'avortement de la femme
une revendication élémentaire physique
de liberté plusieurs d'entre vous ont
dit mes chers collègues que ce droit
existe qu'il est reconnu depuis la loi
veille du 17 janvier 1975 suite ou
mobilisation des femmes d'associations
féministes de syndicalistes et de partis
politiques progressistes alors pourquoi
vouloir le faire entrer dans la
Constitution il est indéniable qu'en
2023 l'avortement continue de rencontrer
une opposition certaine que nous vivons
ici même dans cette hémicycle mes chers
collègues quand il s'agit de faire
progresser les droits des femmes il est
toujours des voix pour exiger de les
encadrer voire de les limiter surtout
concernant la liberté d'avoir ou non un
enfant c'est une situation que l'on
retrouve en France en Europe et dans le
monde en plus de ces blocages
idéologiques j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
développer ici même les embûches
matérielles qui entravent le droit à
l'avortement dans notre pays fermeture
des CIVG manque de personnel pratiquant
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
tes deux a double clauses de conscience
les femmes les plus touchées sont
évidemment les femmes précaires qui
n'ont pas la possibilité d'aller à
l'étranger et laisse ainsi passer le
délai légal c'est une petite musique
qu'on connaît bien qui présente quelques
similitudes avec les années 70 j'espère
donc que le Sénat va se saisir cette
fois-ci de cette PPL pour consolider le
droit à l'IVG si fièrement acquis le
constitutionnalisé est une opportunité
qu'il faut saisir car si le Conseil
constitutionnel a toujours jugé les lois
relatives à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse conforme à la Constitution il
n'a pour autant jamais consacré ce droit
sous la forme d'un droit fondamental
ainsi ne bénéficie que d'une protection
législative et non constitutionnelle
aujourd'hui une loi qui porterait
atteinte au droit à l'IVG ne serait pas
censuré mes collègues la volonté de
constitutionnaliser le droit à
l'avortement n'est pas nouvelle et ne
date pas de la décision de la Cour
suprême des États-Unis du 24 juin 2022
cela fait 11 ans depuis 2012 que le
Parti communiste porte cette idée et le
groupe CRCE avait déposé une proposition
de loi en ce sens dès 2017 nous le
répétons comme nous l'avions soutenu
récemment lors de l'examen de la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
déposée par notre collègue Mélanie Vogel
et dont nous avions été consignataires
il est grand temps de conférer un
interruption volontaire de grossesse le
statut de droit fondamental et de
l'inscrire dans la Constitution afin de
s'assurer que l'accès à l'IVG ne puisse
être affaibli voire supprimer par des
dispositions législatives pour y
parvenir il faut voter la loi conforme à
celle qui a été adoptée à l'Assemblée
nationale ce qui ont vu du rapport de
force semblent quelque peu incertains
néanmoins depuis octobre et le rejet ici
d'une première PPL constitutionnelle les
débats dans la société ont peut-être
contribué rien à faire évoluer certaines
positions c'est ainsi que notre collègue
Philippe Vasse souhaite faire bouger les
lignes avec un amendement situé à
l'article 34 de la Constitution comme
nous le défendions au groupe CRCE la
rédaction la loi détermine les
conditions dans lesquelles s'exerce la
liberté de la femme de mettre fin à sa
grossesse nous pose question et nous
inquiète sur la latitude possible et
c'est au législateur de revenir sur
certaines avancées notamment substituant
le mot liberté au mot droit cela étant
nous sommes conscients que cet
amendement s'il est adopté représente
une ouverture pour permettre à la PPL
constitutionnelle de poursuivre son
parcours législatif notre groupe ne fera
donc rien pour bloquer un tant soit peu
cette proposition de loi en souhaitant
que si l'amendement était voté
majoritairement il pourrait être
rédigé de manière différente reprenant
le mot droit car pour nous c'est
extrêmement important mes chers
collègues comme nous y invite les
associations féministes dont certaines
ici présente et que je salue soyons le
premier pays qui garantisse le 3 à
l'interruption volontaire dans la
Constitution et je vais faire mienne
l'appel d'oser le féminisme en octobre
dernier nous appelons la France à être
pionnière dans la protection du droit à
l'avortement en devenant le premier pays
à constitutionnaliser ce droit
fondamental donnant ainsi un message
d'espoir pour les femmes de ce monde qui
se battent pour leurs droits pour le
respect de leur corps et de leur santé
merci
la parole est maintenant monsieur Loïc
Hervé pour le groupe Union centriste
pour six minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame le rapporteur
mes chers collègues nous sommes réunis
ce soir afin d'examiner pour la deuxième
fois en trois mois
sans compter les nombreux autres textes
déposés sur les bureaux des assemblées
une nouvelle proposition de loi
constitutionnelle visant à protéger et à
garantir le droit fondamental à l'IVG
alicia-t-il de notre collègue député
madame maltilde panot ce texte fut
adopté à l'Assemblée nationale après
avoir été réécrit en première lecture à
une très large majorité le 24 novembre
quelques semaines auparavant c'est le
texte de notre collègue Mélanie Vogel
qui nous était présenté il prévoyait
outre l'IVG d'inscrire également dans le
marbre constitutionnel je mets marbre
entre guillemets la garantie du droit à
la contraception c'est d'ailleurs à
remercier à cet instant notre rapporteur
qui dans la continuité de son précédent
rapport à de nouveaux fait preuve d'une
grande sagesse dans la manière d'aborder
un sujet délicat à la fois sur un plan
politique comme sur un plan sociétal
renvoyant aux convictions intimes et à
l'histoire de chacun et de chacune
d'entre nous
la jeunesse de cette multiplication de
textes c'est bien évidemment l'actualité
américaine ou plutôt l'actualité d'une
juridiction des États-Unis d'Amérique la
Cour suprême qui nous amène aussi peu de
temps à examiner deux propositions de
loi qui ont en gros le même objectif on
est en effet le 24 juin 2022 l'arrêt
d'obs versus Jackson venait opérer une
modification de l'arrêt versus waday du
22 juillet
1973 ce dernier avait fondé une
protection fédérale sous le contrôle de
la Cour suprême du droit l'avortement
sur le 14e amendement de la Constitution
des États-Unis lequel dispose notamment
qu'aucun État je cite ne privera
quiconque de la vie de la liberté ou de
la propriété son procédure légale
régulière désormais il appartient à
chaque État fédéré de légiférer sur
l'interdiction ou non du recours à l'IVG
aurais-je besoin mes chers collègues de
vous rappeler ici la première partie de
l'article premier de la Constitution du
4 octobre 1958 la France est une
République indivisible nous ne sommes
pas une fédération c'est-à-dire que le
législateur national dispose d'une
plénitude des compétences et les lois
sont les mêmes pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens partout sur notre territoire
je le vois donc pas mes chers collègues
de comparaison possible avec le texte de
la Constitution américaine
comme madame le rapporteur nous l'a
rappelé en commission des lois notre
arsenal juridique est suffisamment
solide concernant l'IVG on témoigne la
loi du 17 janvier
1975 portée par Simone Veil ministre de
la Santé relative à l'IVG ces
dispositions n'ont jamais cessé d'être
renforcés par le législateur qu'il
s'agisse de l'allongement successif des
délais de l'élargissement des praticiens
pouvant pratiquer des IVG et elle a été
confortée par le droit constitutionnel
au delà même de cette intégration pleine
et entière dans notre patrimoine
juridique auquel le Sénat est fortement
attaché que force est de constater
aujourd'hui qu'aucun parti y compris aux
extrêmes de l'échiquier politique n'a
jamais appelé à remettre en cause l'IVG
dans son principe on peut d'ailleurs
trouver une illustration de cela dans le
vote de l'Assemblée nationale du 24
novembre dernier puisque pas moins de 38
députés appartenant au rassemblement
national ont été même prêts à inscrire
ce droit dans la Constitution avant de
constitutionnaliser un tel droit je
pense qu'il est nécessaire de regarder
tout d'abord comment il est mis en
oeuvre sur le terrain au quotidien et
malheureusement à l'heure de la
désertification médicale l'accès à l'IVG
est parfois rendu très difficile pour un
certain nombre de femmes sur notre
territoire national la délégation au
droit des femmes à laquelle je m'honore
d'appartenir à l'initiative de notre
collègue la présidente Annick billon
avait déjà souligné ce problème ce
problème d'effectivité dans un rapport
de 2015 femme et santé les enjeux
d'aujourd'hui
insister aujourd'hui en concisualisant
ce droit sur l'effectivité et les
galaxies au droit à l'IVG comme le
propose article unique des propositions
après la publication de ce rapport de la
délégation de la situation la guerre
évolue
avant de conclure un mot sur
l'amendement proposé par notre collègue
Philippe Bas un mot de rappel un peu
procédural tel que j'ai pu le faire ce
matin en commission je veux dire que si
c'est amendement qui choisit une
nouvelle rédaction et une imputation
différente dans la Constitution ne
change rien en termes de Procédure
parlementaires une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle adoptée sur une
rédaction quand bien même conforme
conduirait le président de la République
a convoqué un référendum ou pas il n'y a
pas d'autres
issus possibles à l'échelle de cette
discussion parlementaire
le groupe de l'Union centriste pratique
la liberté de vote de manière générale
il le fait à fortiori sur des sujets dit
de société si certains des membres de
mon groupe soutiendront ce texte comme
ils l'ont fait pour la proposition de
loi de Mélanie Vogel d'autres
s'abstiendront ou ne prendront pas par
vos votes mais la plupart d'entre nous
votre a contre l'amendement de Philippe
Bas ou contre la rédaction de
l'Assemblée nationale suivons ainsi la
vie de la commission des Lois du Sénat
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Madame Corinne Imbert pour le
groupe les républicains pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame la rapporteur
mes chers collègues
après l'examen en octobre dernier de la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
déposée par notre collègue mais la
niveau gel nous voilà nouveau réunis
afin de débattre autour de la question
de la constitutionnalisation de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
je tiens à rappeler que le débat
d'aujourd'hui doit être uniquement
centré sur cette question l'inscription
ou pas du droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution là où certains seraient
tentés d'opposer progressistes vertueux
et conservateurs arriéré je tiens à
rappeler que l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse a été votée grâce à la loi
veille pendant la mandature de Valérie
Giscard d'Estaing président de droite
afin d'éviter certains raccourcis qui ne
seraient pas dignes de la qualité des
débats qui doit prévaloir au sein de
cette émission
[Applaudissements]
lorsque cette thématique est arrivée
dans le débat public j'ai tenté de me
poser objectivement les bonnes questions
afin d'obtenir des réponses qui
dépassent le simple réflexe partisan
quel est le rôle de la Constitution le
droit d'interruption volontaire de
grossesse est-il en danger dans notre
pays l'inscription du droit à l'IVG dans
la Constitution représente-t-elle une
véritable protection supplémentaire dans
la défense de ce droit
tout d'abord je pense que le rôle
fondamental de la Constitution et de
donner la philosophie générale et
j'insiste bien sur ce dernier terme de
la gestion de la direction de notre pays
forme de l'État organisation des
institutions règles de production des
normes interactions entre les différents
pouvoirs je ne crois pas que son rôle
soit d’être bavarde car paradoxalement
cela risquerait de l'affaiblir si l'on
tombe dans un inventaire à la Prévert de
l'ensemble des droits auxquels peuvent
prétendre nos concitoyens alors le
risque d'insatisfaction permanente nous
guette nous devons au contraire être les
garants de la Constitution
ensuite je suis toujours étonnée de voir
certains débats venus d'autres
atlantiques prendre une place si
importante au sein de l'actualité
française
instatiquement la philosophie gaulliste
m'enjoint de ne posséder aux sirènes de
l'actualité court thermiste et je ne
peux que regretter ce phénomène de
transposition de débats qui n'ont bien
souvent pas lieu d'être dans notre pays
quelqu'un dans cette émission peut-il
réellement affirmer que le droit à l'IVG
se trouve aujourd'hui menacé dans notre
pays peut-on comparer une société où la
lutte contre l'IVG est un marqueur
politique fort à une nation ou aucun des
12 derniers candidats à l'élection
présidentielle de ces proposées en
faveur d'un rétrécissement du droit à
l'IVG les réponses mes collègues vous
les avez enfin très attaché au droit à
l'IVG et à la protection de l'enfant à
l'être je me suis imagine un scénario
catastrophe ou une poignée de personnes
hostie d'un interruption volontaire de
grossesse prendrait le pouvoir par la
force et souhaiterait abolir ce droit
durement acquis
pensez-vous sérieusement que la
Constitution empêchera quoi que ce soit
non la Constitution ne pourra alors plus
rien pour l'IVG comme elle ne pourra
plus rien pour les libertés publiques
pour la liberté de la presse ou pour la
liberté de conscience le XXème siècle
européen est rempli d'exemples de pays
qui ont connu à recul des droits
fondamentaux à la suite de l'arrivée au
pouvoir du régime autoritaire
comment croire que l'inscription du
droit l'IVG dans la Constitution
renforcera ce droit à l'IVG ce que je
crois c'est que le débat que nous avons
aujourd'hui traduit un phénomène bien
plus grand qui mine le rôle du politique
dans notre pays le recul progressif de
la capacité à agir sur le réel des
exemples de combat pour les droits des
femmes il en existe pléthore et nous
savons que malgré une amélioration
considérable de la place des femmes dans
notre pays le chemin est encore long
mais voilà nous préférons débattre d'un
sujet qui n'en est plus un ou certains
voient l'opportunité de se placer du bon
côté du récit de faire de l'actualité
comme disent des communicants mes chers
collègues je pense qu'une partie de la
classe politique s'est offerte une
publicité avec ce texte mais que cette
écran de fumée va d'équivalence que
l'incapacité à se saisir de thématique
du réel la posture est facile avoir des
bons sentiments et faciles il est bien
plus difficile de mener à bien des
réformes ambitieuses qui ont un impact
sur le quotidien de nos concitoyens
l'éternel débat de la prévalence du fond
ou de la forme mais l'histoire n'est pas
dupe pour toutes ces raisons et parce
que nous croyons à la prévalence du fond
sur la forme le groupe les républicains
inventera dans sa très grande majorité
contre ses propositions de loi
constitutionnelle je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues la discussion
générale est close la commission n'ayant
pas élaboré de texte nous passons à la
discussion de l'article unique de la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
adoptée par l'Assemblée nationale visant
à protéger garantir le droit fondamental
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
mais chers collègues sur cet article
unique j'ai déjà un certain nombre de
demandes de parole je souhaite
franchement pour l'organisation de nos
travaux que ceux qui souhaitent
s'inscrire sur l'article le fasse
maintenant et pas au fur et à mesure qui
veut s'inscrire sur des prises de parole
sur l'article le seul l'article unique
vous notez
1 2 3 4 5
très bien
c'est noté sur les tableaux
nous commençons donc par Madame Hélène
Conway Mouret
je vous remercie monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
bah circonscription mondiale m'oblige à
constater sur le terrain à la rencontre
des associations au féministes que le
droit à l'avortement est aujourd'hui
remis en question quand il n'est pas
menacé y compris dans des pays
démocratiques nous avons cité déjà la
Pologne les États-Unis mais ils sont
nombreux si ce droit semble aujourd'hui
à qui en France je ne peux qu'invoquer
cette phrase de Benoît de Gould qui
disait à toutes celles qui vivent dans
l'illusion que l'égalité est acquise
rien n'est plus précaire que le droit
des femmes nous avons l'avantage en
France que l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes soient inscrites dans la
constitution et de vivre dans un pays où
les femmes sont libres de disposer de
leur corps même si pour des causes pour
cause de manque de moyens médicaux 3000
à 4000 français sont forcés de se rendre
à l'étranger chaque année car hors
délais et Willy végé continuent d'être
un combat ce droit concerne également
les Françaises vivant à l'étranger pour
la première fois le budget 2023 du
ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères consacrent une ligne
budgétaire qui doit permettre à nos
compatriotes vivant dans des pays où
elles n'ont pas accès à l'IVG d'être
prise en charge afin qu'elle puisse à
pratiquer en France il convient
désormais que l'État accélère le
déploiement de ce dispositif
d'accompagnement voire de rapatriement
et clarifier les conditions d'accès à ce
droit fondamental afin que la protection
consulaire inclut l'assistance à l'IVG
enfin faut-il rappeler que 81% des
Français sont favorables à l'inscriture
du droit à l'IVG dans la Constitution
selon un sondage réalisé en juillet 2022
alors mes chers collègues pour celles et
ceux qui ne sont pas encore convaincus
soyons en phase avec les attentes de nos
compatriotes et surtout ne ratons pas
l'occasion de confirmer l'exemplarité de
la Constitution française en matière des
droits fondamentaux et de protection des
libertés individuelles
merci la parole est maintenant madame
Annick billon pour le groupe Union
centriste merci
président monsieur le garde des sceaux
chers collègues c'est avec force et tout
simplement que je souhaiterais affirmer
devant vous ma position personnelle sur
la PPLC dont nous battons ce soir ce
droit à l'IVG inscrit dans la loi grâce
à la force de l'engagement d'une femme
Simone Veil en 1975 je voterai cette
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
comme j'ai voté en faveur du texte de
notre collègue Mélanie Vogel à l'automne
dernier
j'entends les contestations de mes
collègues qui dénoncent l'inscription
dans la Constitution d'un droit qui ne
serait pas menacé aujourd'hui qui peut
le certifier pas moi j'entends les
opposants à l'IVG qui profitent de ce
débat pour s'opposer à ce droit voir qui
nous intimide ou qui nous menace
parce que l'IVG doit demeurer un droit
fondamental pour les femmes
inscrivons-le dans la Constitution je
voterai ce texte tout en étant
consciente qu'il ne constitue pas une
fin en soi le vote aujourd'hui est une
étape un signe envoyer à toutes les
femmes un signe envoyé au gouvernement
n'oublions cependant pas que graver
l'IVG dans notre Constitution n'aura de
légitimité que si son accès demeure
garanti partout sur notre territoire
pour toutes les femmes nous pouvons nous
accorder je crois sur cela actuellement
il ne l'est toujours pas ce vote nous
oblige à y remédier au plus vite c'est
un impératif de santé publique face à un
délit de non d'insistance à femmes en
danger au delà des rédactions proposées
la question qui nous est posée ce soir
chers collègues elle est simple
souhaitons-nous consolider ce droit à
l'IVG ma réponse est oui je vous
remercie
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole la parole est maintenant
madame Elsa Charles
dis donc monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues la question qui nous est posée
par ce texte et de savoir si nous
voulons apporter une garantie
constitutionnelle au droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse à
titre personnel je le souhaite et je
voterai aujourd'hui comme en octobre
dernier pour la constitutionnalisation
de cette liberté fondamentale pour les
femmes pourquoi parce que la
Constitution est notre texte à valeur
suprême elle est le socle commun des
valeurs et des libertés fondamentales de
notre société celle auxquelles nous ne
devons pas déroger inscrire l'IVG dans
la Constitution c'est inscrire ce droit
fondamental au sommet de notre
hiérarchie des normes c'est sacralisé un
droit qui a fait l'objet de très
nombreux combats pour faire partie de
notre patrimoine juridique fondamental à
l'heure où les droits des femmes en
général et le droit à l'avortement
particulier peuvent faire l'objet de
recul dans des pays pas si lointains et
même si la situation américaine n'est
pas comparable à la nôtre j'ai la
conviction que conférer la plus haute
protection à ce droit et pertinent les
droits des femmes nécessitent notre
constante vigilance notre mobilisation
et notre action de chaque instant
l'absence actuelle de remise en cause
dans notre pays de l'IVG ne saurait nous
exonérer de tout faire pour protéger et
garantir dès aujourd'hui ce droit auquel
nous sommes tous attachés
la parole est maintenant madame Muriel
jourdat
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur président de la
condition des lois Madame mes chers
collègues j'avoue que j'ai quelques
difficultés à reconnaître le Sénat dans
ses débats qui nous animent et qui nous
animent peut-être longtemps puisqu'il
n'y a pas eu moins de 6pl qui ont été
déposés sur ce sujet j'ai d'édifié à le
reconnaître parce que nous nous ventons
souvent d'une certaine sagesse
sénatoriale et je ne la reconnais pas
dans ce débat car la réalité est que
nous réagissons comme de vulgaire
tabloïdes à un événement qui ne nous
concerne pas qui ne nous regarde pas qui
est une décision de la Cour suprême des
États-Unis qui n'a aucun impact sur la
France de la même façon que notre
décision n'aura aucun impact sur les
États-Unis et cela me paraît assez
surprenant j'avoue que je suis aussi
surprise parce que nous avons l'habitude
de faire preuve d'une certaine
objectivité or ici j'entends que nous
débattons de l'IVG comme si c'était le
sujet de ce soir et comme si
véritablement une menace
faisait sur cette liberté des femmes en
France vous savez que ça n'est pas le
cas vous savez que nous ne discutons pas
de l'IVG et vous savez aussi que même si
l'on brandit assez facilement la menace
de l'extrême droite qui pourrait nous
priver de cette liberté à l'Assemblée
nationale l'extrême droite a
majoritairement voté pour la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG donc là
encore nous manquons d'objectivité nous
avons aussi généralement une certaine
rigueur juridique lorsque nous parlons
et aujourd'hui j'entends parler de la
Constitution comme si c'était un
fourre-tout dans lequel nous pouvions
inscrire tout ce qui nous tenait à cœur
et que ça protégeait comme un
coffre-fort là aussi vous savez que
c'est faux vous savez que là la
Constitution et bien c'est l'ensemble
des règles qui régissent nos
institutions qu'elle n'est pas
intangible puisque nous l'avons modifié
24 fois depuis 1958 et que probablement
cette liberté n'a pas grand chose à y
faire même si le Conseil constitutionnel
a indiqué quel découdait d'une liberté
déjà prévue dans la Constitution qui est
la liberté des femmes et enfin j'ai
l'habitude aussi me d'un certain respect
ici or j'entends que certains auraient
des positions dignes et d'autres dans
n'auraient pas nous avons toujours des
positions d'inities elles sont diverses
mais elles doivent pour être acceptées
et pour ma part je ne voterai pas ce
texte
20 secondes je dis rien alors merci
c'est moi qui gère le temps
merci madame Jourdain
la parole
la parole est à la présidente Rossignol
et à elle seule monsieur le Président je
m'étais inscrite parce qu'évidemment
c'est un débat sur lequel j'ai des
éléments à partager avec le Sénat et
puis je vois les inscrits
s'afficher de plus en plus nombreux au
fur et à mesure du débat je vois même
des collègues qui ont ce qu'ils ont
exprimés dans la discussion générale
s'inscrire de nouveau sur l'article et
je sais qu'après cet article il y a
l'amendement de fit du questerba qui va
donner lieu aussi à des prises de parole
et plus je sais qu'à 20h45 tout s'arrête
donc je ne voudrais pas que le Sénat
ayant déjà il y a quelques temps au mois
d'octobre était remarqué pour son vote
hostile à la Constitution soit
aujourd'hui remarqué pour une manœuvre
de procédures qui consisterait à faire
durer le débat et à ce que nous ne
puissions pas voter aujourd'hui ni
l'amendement de Philippe Bani le texte
voilà
comme l'a dit nous avons déjà ce n'est
pas la première fois que nous discutons
ni de l'IVG ni de la
constitutionnalisation donc comme l'a
dit le président karouchi c'est moi et
moi seul qui parle et je passe mon tour
de parole au profit d'un vote dans les
temps
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues avec ce que je viens
d'entendre j'aimerais quand même
rappeler l'organisation des travaux
parlementaires ce soir le groupe
socialiste dispose d'une niche de 4
heures il y a deux textes dans cette
niche là on a on a on va débattre de
quatre rédactions différentes de cette
inscription dans la Constitution on a le
droit monsieur le Président d'avoir le
temps nécessaire pour débattre de ces de
ces différentes rédactions qui touchent
au texte fondamental de la République
française et moi ce projet d'attention
là je ne l'entends pas
et bien
allez
jusqu'ici ça restait serein moi je me
contente d'appliquer le règlement et de
donner la parole à Monsieur delege
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues je ne cherche pas à faire
durer le débat mais il est suffisamment
important que chacun puisse s'exprimer
et je voudrais faire trois observations
rapidement la première on a eu un débat
tout à l'heure sur le point de savoir si
c'était un droit qu'il fallait conforter
ou un symbole qu'il fallait afficher en
ce qui me concerne je pense que la
Constitution c'est pas un symbole
c'est quelque chose de sérieux et
puisqu'on lui parle des libertés on
parle de la liberté où certains
souhaitent y inscrire la liberté
d'avortement mais demain pourquoi pas la
fin de vie pourquoi pas la PMA je ne
pense pas que ce soit le lieu la
Constitution d'inscrire ces questions
sociétales la deuxième chose que je
voulais dire au ministre c'est que il
appelle encore ce n'était pas très clair
est-ce que nous votions conformes pour
qu'on puisse avancer donc organiser le
référendum mais Monsieur le Ministre
est-ce que vraiment le gouvernement
souhaite en ce moment organiser un
référendum êtes-vous certain que c'est
le moment le plus apaisé pour avoir un
débat apaisé sur une question aussi
grave que celle là enfin troisième
réflexion j'ai cru comprendre que le
président de la public va tout prix
laisser son nom attaché à la
Constitution et qu'il conque une réforme
constitutionnelle ne pensez-vous pas
monsieur le ministre qui serait bon
d'avoir une vision complète et éviter de
réformer la Constitution en fonction des
aléas de l'actualité Fustel américaines
merci
la parole est maintenant Madame
Jacqueline au stage Brignoud
merci monsieur le Président alors ne
nous trompons pas de débats chers
collègues la question n'est pas celle de
remettre en cause des droits ouverts par
la loi veille le sujet est de savoir si
les pertinent pour nous parlementaires
français de nous emparer d'une
problématique qui s'est en réalité posée
à la société américaine avec toutes les
spécificités de cette société aux
États-Unis et non à notre pays et même
moi je pense que non et je voudrais
m'adresser à toutes les femmes qui nous
regardent aujourd'hui pour leur dire que
le recours à l'IVG n'est absolument pas
remis en cause en France puisqu'il
s'agit de l'un de nos droits
fondamentaux la position constante du
Conseil constitutionnel sur ce sujet est
extrêmement protectrice le recours à
l'IVG découle de la liberté de la femme
tirée de l'article 2 de la Déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen de
1789 inscrire
dispositif quel qu'il soit dans la
Constitution n'aurait qu'une conséquence
fragiliser le recours à l'IVG et il me
semble qu'il n'est pas souhaitable
d'attisé des peurs fondés sur la
situation d'autres pays et compte tenu
de la situation déjà particulièrement
anxiogène que connaissent nos
concitoyens il me semble
inutile d'en rajouter pour l'ensemble de
ces raisons comme de nombreux collègues
qui sont à mes côtés dans le groupe LR
je m'opposerai et je ne voterai pas
cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle comme je l'ai fait en
cohérence déjà il y a quelques semaines
et je voudrais préciser que je n'aurais
pas honte de mon vote
alors c'est à qui là
la parole est maintenant à Madame
Mercier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame le rapporteur
c'est vrai que j'ai l'habitude de
m'exprimer quand il s'agit de ces sujets
de société mais là en fait on ferait du
au cas où ce serait un symbole or le
législateur il est quand même chargé
d'écrire la loi pas de légiférer sur des
symboles d'ailleurs c'est quoi des
symboles étymologiquement c'est pas si
simple le symbole c'est un fait évoquant
par une correspondance analogique
formelle naturelle ou culturelle quelque
chose d'absent ou d'impossible à
percevoir mes chers collègues est-ce que
vous croyez vraiment honnêtement que la
protection du droit à l'IVG que je
défends de toute mon âme est absente ou
impossible à percevoir le Conseil
constitutionnel dès 1975 à valider la
loi sur l'IVG en soulignant de son
article premier qui renonce le principe
du respect de tout être humain dès le
commencement de la vie doit pouvoir
connaître des limites soit précisément
ce droit que nous revendiquons à l'IVG
26 ans plus tard le Conseil a renforcé
encore la protection de ce droit donc je
voudrais vous dire mes chers collègues
les femmes elles n'ont pas besoin de
symboles elle ne veulent pas de symbole
les femmes elles veulent des moyens
elles veulent des plannings familiaux
elle veut des médecins nous voulons une
éducation sexuelle digne de ce nom nous
voulons un accompagnement psychologique
parce que quelquefois on parle de la
liberté de la femme à avorter vous êtes
sûr mes chers collègues quelquefois la
femme elle n'avortent pas parce que son
compagnon lui a demandé de le faire et
qu'elle se sent obligé de le faire il
faut les accompagner les femmes les
aider et nous devons nous attacher à ça
plutôt qu'à inscrire quelque chose dans
la Constitution c'est pas ça qui nous
aidera
merci la parole est maintenant madame
bourra
mes chers collègues la baisse de
confiance accordée par nos concitoyens à
la classe politique en général et à
l'exécutif en particulier nous oblige
sans cesse rappeler par les baromètres
d'opinion cette confiance abîmée qui
confine parfois même à la défiance et
souvent le fruit des incohérences que
nos concitoyens
identifient dans les discours tenus par
leur représentants elle nous oblige
parce que la politique c'est d'abord des
convictions nous avons voté contre la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG le 12
octobre 2022 en commission des Lois du
Sénat nous avons voté contre la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG le 19
octobre 2022 en séance publique au Sénat
nous avons voté contre la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG le
premier février 2023 en commission des
Lois du Sénat je vais donc faire preuve
de cohérence et je voterai donc la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG ce soir
en séance publique
merci la parole maintenant madame
difolco merci monsieur le Président
alors depuis
nos débats j'ai écouté
qu'un de vous et surtout les bancs de
cette émission le sujet principal qui
semble nous occuper celui de
constitutionnalisation
chers collègues je vous le dis vous je
pense
voyons
le retenir aujourd'hui
et sur lequel nous devons nous
concitoyens de concentrer tous nos
efforts et de mon point de vue celui
d'effectivité
dire qu'une norme juridique est
effective c'est dire qu'elle existe dans
la réalité et qu'elle est appliquée dans
les faits cette exception classique de
l'éminant doyen carbonier dans un
article précurseur de 1958 renvoie à une
application effective des normes nous
sommes favorables à l'effectivité du
recours à l'IVG mais l'effectivité ne se
limite pas à l'application d'une règle
elle doit aussi recouvrir une dimension
symbolique or comme le doyen favoro
l'énonçait si le législateur peut
abroger certaines des règles qui
protègent ou favorisent l'exercice de
droit fondamentaux il ne pourrait pas le
faire au point que ses droits n'est plus
d'effectivité dès lors ne nous trompons
pas quand elle a question juridique qui
nous est posée faut-il ajouter à votre
texte fondamental une disposition
déclarative je ne le crois pas je n'en
ai pas honte madame Vogel où faut-il
agir concrètement en faveur de l'accès
effectif de toutes les femmes à l'IVG
j'en suis persuadé et je mets le
gouvernement face à ces obligations en
la matière je vous remercie
la parole monsieur Loïc Hervé oui
monsieur le prison qui s'exprimera à
titre personnel contrairement à tout à
l'heure où je prenais de la parole au
nom du groupe d'union centriste il y a
plusieurs débats il y a le débat de
l'influence internationale sur nos
débats intérieurs il y a la question de
l'opportunité de savoir s'il faut mettre
cette référence à l'IVG dans la
Constitution mais il y a un débat qui
est un débat juridique et dans le rappel
au règlement je rappelais qu'on en est à
quatre rédactions
il y a la rédaction de Madame Vogel il y
a la rédaction initiale de Madame panot
il y a
il y a la rédaction de l'Assemblée
nationale et on aura à débattre tout à
l'heure de la rédaction proposée par
Philippe le tout dans des délais
contraints avec une proposition de loi
deuxième véhicule légitime et d'une
proposition de loi donc pas d'impact pas
de passage au Conseil d'État et pas de
débat en droit et en plus avec une
procédure dont on sait tous qu'elle
n'ira pas à son terme puisque la seule
issue c'est le référendum dans la
situation actuelle du pays avec quatre
rédactions et une issue hypothétique et
celle du référendum est-ce que ceux qui
sont les défenseurs de l'IVG imaginent
une seconde ce que représentera un débat
sur une question sociétale de cette
ampleur là dans l'état actuel de la
société française je pose la question
comme ça parce qu'en fait il y a un
moment on est non seulement dans cette
maison on arrête de faire du droit
et on parle que de sujets politiques en
disant c'est très bien de mettre ce
sujet dans la Constitution moi j'y suis
je suis hostile à cette inscription mais
si on devait imaginer de le faire
faudrait quand même se poser la question
de la qualité du droit qu'on écrit
on est quand même des législateurs et ce
dont on parle c'est la qualité de la
Constitution pour les pour les années
qui viennent une loi ça se fait ça se
défait une constitution ça se ça se
défait pas aussi simplement que ça donc
on est en train de on est en train mes
chers collègues
d'improviser et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il fallait faire ce rappel là à
cet instant
merci
merci je demande vraiment à chacun de ce
contenu de se retenir pour le moment le
débat il serein ça ne sert strictement à
rien de l'envenimer il reste 35 minutes
on va le faire calmement
la parole est au président Retailleau
merci monsieur le Président de ce
préalable bien entendu il n'y a pas d'un
côté le camp de la dignité et le camp de
l'indignité nos démocraties s'abîmes
quand on réduit le débat public à une
polarisation à un échange de
condamnation et d'accusation on doit
pouvoir en débattre quelle que soit les
opinions des uns ou des autres moi je
pense que nous sommes le Sénat et je
pense que le Sénat ne doit pas
fonctionner sous la pression de tel ou
tel opinion publique mais que nous
devons légiférer de façon rationnelle et
raisonnable cette PPLC est-elle
rationnelle je ne le crois pas parce que
le droit à l'IVG et je remercie Agnès
canailler notre rapporteur qu'il a très
bien démontré n'est pas menacé dans son
existence même en France par aucune
formation politique et le Conseil
constitutionnel en quelque sorte
constitutionnaliser ce droit à l'IVG
puisque que il a indiqué dans un certain
nombre de ses décisions qu'il
constituait un élément de la liberté
fondamentale de la femme
cette PPLC est-elle aussi raisonnable
est-ce raisonnable chers collègues
d'importer dans notre pays déjà si
fracturé les débats qui fractuent la
société américaine est-il raisonnable
aussi de vouloir sur un tel sujet
monsieur le ministre garde des sceaux
est-il raisonnable de vouloir un
référendum parce que vous avez
pertinemment que pour que cela aboutisse
il faudra passer par le référendum enfin
est-il raisonnable de vouloir
constitutionnaliser à tout va Dominique
delache à très bien dit demain si on a
par exemple le droit au suicide assisté
il y a la PMA pour toutes pourquoi donc
ces droits serait-il de porter inférieur
à l'IVG pourquoi donc demain ne
devrions-nous pas aussi les
constitutionnalisés je pense que la
Constitution la Constitution française
de la Cinquième République elle n'est
pas faite pour adresser des messages
symboliques au monde entier
merci
la parole est maintenant monsieur ravier
merci monsieur le Président je l'ai dit
répéter j'ai même organisé un coloc qui
s'y même au Sénat pour le démontrer et
j'en ai été d'ailleurs très heureux la
constitutionnalisation du droit l'IVG
est inutile et dangereuse elle est
inutile car il n'y a pas de sujet chez
nous en France le droit à l'IVG n'est
pas menacé alors pourquoi cette
proposition pourquoi cette obsession de
la gauche la principale raison la
frustration la frustration politique la
loi de dépénalisation de 1900 la loi de
tout de suite donnez-moi la parole de
tout la séance est suspendue
huissier évacuer la tribune évacuer la
tribune si je
si jeune et
déjà idéologiquement contaminé
je représente je reprends donc après
après ces agités
jusqu'à 20h45
et que naturellement et comme il se doit
nous saurons qui a invité ces personnes
c'est la règle c'est la règle
je vous rappelle que l'article 91 du
Règlement du Sénat prévoit que le public
admis dans les tribunes se tient assis
découvert et en silence et que toute
personne donnant des marques
d'approbation d'improbation est exclue
sur le champ
je reprends donc mon propos la
principale raison la frustration la
frustration politique la loi de
dépénalisation 1960 de 1975 a été pensé
rédigé et proposé par un ministre de
droite si monsaï soutenu par une
majorité un gouvernement et un président
de la République de droite alors depuis
48 ans la gauche ne l'a toujours pas
digéré elle rumine elle en rage d'abord
été dépossédée de ce qui lui revenait
idéologiquement de droit au même titre
que l'abolition de la peine de mort elle
a saisi une actualité tronquée venue
d'outre Atlantique pour un grand coup
d'agide propre comme la scie justement
qualifiée l'ancien secrétaire général du
Conseil constitutionnel tenter d'imposer
son hold-up politique comptant sur la
faiblesse de ses opposants qui s'est
exprimée à l'Assemblée nationale elle
souhaite ainsi récupérer son patrimoine
idéologique mais je vous mets en garde
mes chers collègues de droite nous
sommes en face d'une gauche française
minée par son fanatisme qu'il a poussera
à exiger toujours plus de vous
après la constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
ce sera la constitutionnalisation de la
fin de vie et de l'euthanasie si vous
posez un genou à terre mes chers
collègues elle exigera que vous posiez
le second après que vous ayez posé le
second à l'exigera que vous mettiez à
plat ventre si vous vous mettez à plat
ventre elle vous fera ramper ce sont des
fanatiques il n'en n'ont jamais assez
alors je vous invite mes chers collègues
de droite à rester debout fort et fier
de votre vote j'en appelle à votre
courage et à votre esprit de résistance
ne lâchez rien ne lâchez rien pardon
lapsus lapsus révélateur votre vote
notre vote nous engage à tous ne laissez
pas allez c'est terminé monsieur ravier
vous n'avez plus la parole mais
qu'est-ce que c'est ça je croyais qu'on
pouvait courir vous voyez qu'on pouvait
couper la parole qu'est-ce que c'est que
ce cirque ah bah oui c'est trop tard ah
ben oui mais c'est trop tard merci
merci Monsieur ravier merci Monsieur
ravier
la parole est à Monsieur bonne Carrère
et si chacun pouvait retrouver son calme
en attendant que l'on sache les suites
de l'incident
il a pas de micro
c'est bon c'est bon monsieur oui
monsieur le Président je mets chers
collègues je vous proposerai que nous
oublions les incidents auxquels nous
venons d'assister
il est bien évident qu'il desservent la
cause qu'il voudrait défendre et je suis
quand même trop respectueux même si je
ne partage pas les positions qui ont été
présentées par les soutiens de cette
proposition de loi je suis trop
respectueux de l'importance que vous
apportez à ce sujet pour que nous ayons
une appréciation par rapport à ce type
d'incidence je vous propose vraiment que
nous les oublions 3
réserves pour justifier pour la majorité
de notre groupe un vote négatif le
premier vous le comprenez bien concerne
notre Constitution notre Constitution
c'est le socle c'est ce qui nous a
permis de faire face à des moments
difficiles c'est un élément de stabilité
et une constitution c'est d'abord le
fonctionnement de nos institutions si
nous avons une constitution qui évolue
vers un recueil de dispositions
sociétales et je crois que ce soir nous
ouvririons une porte qui me un petit peu
dit un petit peu difficile je crois que
nous ne rendrions pas service à notre
Constitution et au fonctionnement de
notre système
deuxièmement vous dire que
la société française est déjà assez
troublée l'idée d'un référendum alors
que d'autres sujets de référendum fusent
dans la société française je vous trouve
vraiment bien joueur d'envisager je peux
jouer à entre guillemets bien entendu
d'envisager de passer par la voix du
référendum en cette matière troisième et
dernière élément
ont été évoqués bien sûr le fait que la
dispositions de la Cour suprême
américaine ne nous concerne ni de près
ni loin mais je voulais simplement
attirer votre attention sur le fait que
si vous partez de l'idée que demain
notre système parlementaire pourrait
être complètement renversé et que notre
système constitutionnel pourrait
conduire le Conseil constitutionnel à
revenir sur Charger espérance de depuis
le 1 c'est que vraiment alors là on a un
problème majeur dans notre société pour
arriver à un tel défaut de confiance sur
notre Parlement et sur le Conseil
constitutionnel
madame Gatel j'imagine je pense que
c'est la dernière oratrice mais bon
merci merci
de voler à l'apaisement le sujet dont
nous parlons est un sujet
éminemment important il s'agissait dans
un premier temps de permettre
l'effectivité d'un droit et nous avons
fait un pas de côté sur une autre
réponse à une question qui est celle de
la capacité de notre pays à faire
respecter un droit qui est celui du
droit à l'IVG qui était porté par une
femme qui appartient à la même famille
politique que nous les centrises et que
je regrette qu'ici nous oublions parfois
que nous sommes un lieu de raison un
lieu de fabrique de la loi un lieu
d'opinion et un lieu de liberté et que
je voudrais dire que je soutiens
parfaitement les propos qui ont été
tenus par leur rapporteur elle a un
discours extrêmement rigoureux et
factuel deuxièmement je voudrais dire
que je trouve fort inconvenant que l'on
n'ose évoquer ici peut-être pas
clairement
allusion sous-entendus qu'il y aurait le
camp des biens pensants et celui des
conservateurs qui seraient peut-être
même des mécréants et enfin je refuse
enfin avec tout le respect que j'ai pour
nos collègues socialistes et je sais
l'importance qu'ils accordent à ça je
refuse qu'à la sortie de cette PPL si
elle n'était pas votée parce que le
temps n'aurait pas été respecté on
incombe la responsabilité à ceux qui ont
aussi le droit de s'exprimer et qu'il
appartient à chacun quand on a une niche
de choisir ses sujets et le temps qui
est donné je vous remercie
merci
[Applaudissements]
et bien nous allons passer à
l'amendement de Monsieur Philippe Bas
qui a la parole
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues je vous propose d'effacer
totalement la proposition qui nous vient
de l'Assemblée nationale pour écrire que
la loi détermine les conditions dans
lesquelles s'exercent la liberté de la
femme de maître fin à sa grossesse c'est
une formule qu'on retrouve fréquemment
dans l'énoncé des libertés
constitutionnelles elle permet de
préserver l'équilibre de la loi veille
je me réjouis que sur tous les bancs on
est manifesté ainsi fort attachement à
la loi veille elle permet aussi au
législateur de ne pas abdiquer ses
droits en faveur du pouvoir constituant
car la loi veille pourra continuer à
évoluer vous savez que si elle avait été
cristallisée dans la Constitution aucune
évolution n'aurait été possible y
compris celle des dernières années et
donc là le sujet reste un sujet
législatif mais s'il y avait un
changement
la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel la liberté de la femme
enceinte
de mettre fin à sa grossesse serait
préservée je ne crois à aucun moment à
une telle évolution jurisprudentielle
c'est pour ça que je reconnais bien
volontiers que cette garantie réelle est
aussi virtuelle mais après tout pour le
cas où il y aura une telle inflexion de
la jurisprudence du Conseil constitution
je ne vois pas pourquoi nous nous
priverons de l'avantage d'avoir inscrit
dans le marbre de la Constitution une
liberté qui est déjà reconnue comme une
liberté de rang constitutionnelle par le
Conseil constitutionnel et cela depuis
plus de 20 ans une liberté d'ailleurs à
laquelle nous sommes tous profondément
attachés
merci je précise tout de suite mais vous
l'avez vu sur le tableau qu'il n'y a
plus de sous amendement donc il n'y a
que l'amendement de Philippe avis de la
commission sur cet amendement madame la
rapporteur oui merci monsieur le
Président alors effectivement c'est
amendement
modifie entièrement et considérablement
la proposition de loi mais nous
émettrons et la Commission à émi un avis
défavorable en effet cet amendement est
contraire à la position qui a été
adoptée par le Sénat en octobre dernier
puisque nous restons cohérents nous
pensons que la loi veille garantit
l'avortement en France et que c'est une
garantie forte pour les femmes et qu'il
n'y a pas lieu de constitutionnaliser
alors qu'il n'y a aucune remise en cause
de l'IVG en France aujourd'hui
a supposer que cet amendement comme
l'indique l'auteur ne change rien à
l'existant alors on peut se poser la
question de à quoi sert-il nous sommes
opposés je les ai déjà dit à la
constitutionnalisation pour le symbole
et la commission des lois c'est toujours
opposée à un droit strictement expressif
sur le fond en fait mais l'auteur le
reconnaît cet amendement n'apporte rien
n'ajoute rien au droit positifs puisque
l'article 34 de la Constitution prévoit
déjà que la loi détermine les garanties
fondamentales accordées aux citoyens
pour l'exercice des libertés publiques
et donc intègre évidemment le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
de plus et je le redis et je pense que
il est important que la Constitution de
1958 ne soit pas un catalogue de droit
et de liberté qui en changerait la
nature catalogue de droits et de liberté
parce que évidemment c'est sans fin on
pourrait en ajouter d'autres comme la
liberté de la femme la liberté du voyage
la liberté entreprendre etc etc et
ensuite Simone Veil avait elle-même dit
et je le redis qu'on ne
constitutionnalisait pas pour le symbole
qu'on constitutionnalisait simplement
pour ajouter un droit nouveau ce qui
n'est pas le cas pour cette amendement
ensuite et enfin si vraiment on
considère qu'il est nécessaire de
constitutionnaliser de consacrer la
jurisprudence du Conseil constitutionnel
notamment ce qui concerne l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse alors chers
collègues il manque une partie du
raisonnement émis par le Conseil
constitutionnel puisque l'amendement ne
fait pas expressément référence à la
nécessaire consignation avec la
sauvegarde du principe de dignité de la
personne humaine que le Conseil
constitutionnel concilie toujours avec
la liberté pour la femme de mettre fin à
sa grossesse et enfin dernière argument
je réitère que nous sommes dans le cadre
d'une proposition de loi et cette
procédure impose le recours au
référendum et engager un référendum sur
ce sujet n'est absolument pas
responsable c'est pour ça que nous
émettons un avis défavorable
merci avec du gouvernement monsieur le
garde des sceaux
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le questeur Philippe Bas
tout à l'heure vous avez dit que j'avais
les mains dans les poches n'est-ce pas
je dois vous rappeler que non seulement
je n'ai pas les mains dans les poches
mais je n'ai pas non plus la langue dans
la poche et que j'ai exprimé à de
nombreuses reprises le fait que le
gouvernement soutiendrait les
initiatives parlementaires et je trouve
assez singulier d'entendre dans votre
bouche je vous le dis avec beaucoup de
sympathie au fond que vous ayez besoin
d'une impulsion gouvernementale vous qui
souvent être
l'ardent défenseur du du parlementarisme
et de ses initiatives souvent heureuses
pour ne pas dire toujours je suis assez
surpris de ça il y a eu six textes qui
ont été présentés moi j'ai dit la
première ministre a dit non seulement
nous les regardons mais nous les
soutiendrons
bon et d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs et et
d'ailleurs
laisser le travail parlementaire se
terminer
mais j'ai bien compris il y a aussi une
navette
voilà et nul ne l'ignore alors pour le
reste je veux saluer votre votre
proposition qui démontre à l'évidence
presque dire comme toujours votre
volonté de parvenir à une écriture de
compromis n'est-ce pas
voilà mais j'ai un petit doute je l'ai
exprimé tout à l'heure je ne vais pas le
redire je pense que c'est l'état du
droit actuel et donc
regarde cette amendement
qui fait un pas vers le compromis le
Gouvernement émet un avis de sagesse
merci Monsieur le gardeesse
et on reste un peu calme j'ai déjà
plusieurs demandes de parole
d'explication de vote sur l'amendement
alors pour de bon cette fois-ci levez la
main une fois alors
allons-y une lampe mais moi ça m'est
complètement égal
pas de regret et ben on y va la parole
est d'abord à madame la Présidente
merci monsieur le Président le débat
aujourd'hui porte sur l'amendement
déposé par questerba la question du
gouvernement viendra après et je me
concentrerai aujourd'hui sur cet
amendement pour dire qu'en ce qui
concerne mon groupe et elle le diront si
le temps est possible pour tous les
groupes qui avaient soutenus et
participé à la proposition de droite et
posée par Mélanie Vogel au mois
d'octobre nous allons voter l'amendement
de Philippe Bas et je voudrais dire au
collègue qui pense que la Constitution
n'est pas faite pour être un catalogue
que le droit à l'IVG n'est pas n'importe
quelle liberté qu'aujourd'hui si nous en
parlons c'est bien parce que c'est la
liberté des femmes le droit des femmes
systématiquement mise en cause par tous
les gouvernements il libéraux et ceux
qui disent qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de danger pour demain sont bien
optimistes bien optimiste mes chers
collègues écoutez ce que nous dit notre
collègue gravier
tu es la forme et le fond de son
intervention qui d'entre nous peut dire
monsieur ravier ne représente pas un
courant politique à 1,5% dans le temps
de pays monsieur ravier représente un
courant politique dont on sait très bien
qu'il peut un jour gouverner ce pays et
aujourd'hui voter un amendement qui
inscrit dans la Constitution la liberté
la liberté des femmes d'accéder à
l'avortement s'est envoyé un signal à
qui non pas aux jeunes gens qui
manifestaient il y a 10 jours en
demandant au Sénat de ne pas voter la
constitutionnalisation envoyer un signal
à tous les progressistes qui veulent la
constitutionnalisation à ses 80% de
français notre vote il dira qui nous
parlons aux adversaires de l'IVG ou à
ceux qui promouvent les droits des
femmes voilà parce que les sols qui vous
ont demandé les seuls qui vous ont
demandé aujourd'hui de ne les sols qui
nous demandent de ne pas voter la
constitutionnalisation les sols qui
manifestent pour nous il y a des
manifestations il nous demande de ne pas
pauvreté ce sont les adversaires de
l'IVG à eux il faut dire non nous votons
parce que nous défendons le droit des
femmes leur liberté leur liberté aucune
femme ne peut en être privé c'est ce que
dit l'amendement balle
merci de participer à la sérénité allez
madame Cohen
[Musique]
mes chers collègues c'est quand même
assez
disons troublant de voir que dès qu'il
s'agit d'aborder
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
il y a un débat qui devient extrêmement
passionné et beaucoup de tumulte
moi je veux simplement dire mes chers
collègues écoutez les écouter les
arguments au lieu de vociférer écouter
les arguments pour l'instant je ne les
ai pas avancés vous ne pouvez pas savoir
si vous allez vous inscrire en pour ou
en compte ce que je veux dire je dis
simplement que c'est tout le c'est un
constat c'est un fait alors sur
l'amendement de Monsieur bah je l'ai dit
dans mon propos liminaire j'y vois un
signe positif parce que ça pourrait
permettre au Sénat rassemblé de dire oui
il y a nécessité de constitutionnaliser
ce droit et je trouve que même en étant
mon groupe l'ensemble de mon groupe et
moi-même plutôt en désaccord qu'il y ait
seulement le mot liberté parce que pour
nous l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse n'est pas seulement une
liberté c'est un droit et un droit
charmant acquis et nous aurions souhaité
qu'il y ait ces deux termes après je
vous appelle à la réflexion pourquoi
quand il s'agit de ce droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
il est toujours indispensable de faire
des compromis et de l'encadrer voire de
dire ce que j'ai entendu là encore c'est
un fait on ne peut pas tout mettre
n'importe quoi dans la Constitution
demandez demandez entendez ce que nous
demandons c'est à dire que ce droit soit
considéré comme un droit fondamental
parce que c'est un droit fondamental
pour les femmes qui sont des êtres
majeurs à égalité dans ce pays et dans
le monde de pouvoir décider d'avoir une
grossesse ou pas quand elle le souhaite
pour moi pour l'ensemble de mon groupe
c'est un droit fondamental et je pense
que par rapport à ce qui se passe dans
le pays il y a des collègues d'autres
camps politiques ou d'autres bancs
politiques qui peuvent partager ça donc
je vous je vous encourage à réfléchir et
à voter l'amendement de Monsieur bas
madame Jourda
merci monsieur le Président c'est assez
curieux parce que notre collègue madame
Cohen de votre race est amendement tout
en étant en désaccord avec ces termes et
moi je ne le voterai pas tout en pensant
que c'est plutôt une amélioration par
rapport à la rédaction initiale puisque
effectivement
il me paraît plus juridiquement précis
car une droite un droit et une liberté
ça n'est pas tout à fait la même chose
et sans pouvoir disposer du temps
nécessaire pour retracer l'existence de
cette liberté c'est effectivement une
liberté et non pas un droit et on peut
au moins reconnaître ce mérite à
l'amendement de Philippe Bas qui est de
dire exactement ce que sont les choses
pour autant je reprendrai mais
évidemment beaucoup plus rapidement
l'argumentation de madame le rapporteur
cette liberté pour les femmes de pouvoir
recourir à l'avortement elle découle
déjà d'une liberté constitutionnellement
reconnue et nous n'allons pas inscrire
dans la Constitution toute la liberté
qui découle de la Constitution elle-même
sauf à en faire effectivement un code
qui serait tout à fait inutilisable et
qui ne servirait plus à ce à quoi est
destiné la Constitution je le rappelle
et pour finir puisqu'il me reste
quelques secondes je voudrais tout de
même rappeler comme je l'ai fait tout à
l'heure mes manifestement il faut le
rappeler que que nous ne sommes pas ici
entre partisans de l'IVG et opposant à
l'IVG comme je l'entends on peut
parfaitement ne pas voter ce texte il y
a tout à fait favorable à cette liberté
des femmes de recourir à l'IVG
et évidemment on peut dire que les
droits ne sont jamais acquis les
libertés ne sont jamais acquises c'est
exact mais il faut quand même être
sérieux depuis 1975 les parlementaires
quel que soit leur opinion sur la
question car il y a des parlementaires
qui sont opposés à l'IVG ils en ont
parfaitement le droit n'ont jamais
déposé un quel contexte pour revenir sur
la loi veille et toutes les
modifications qui ont été faites et qui
sont au nombre de 7 ont toujours rendu
plus aisés l'exercice de cette liberté
alors arrêtons de nous faire peur pour
des choses qui n'existent pas
aujourd'hui rien n'est menacé et il ne
sert à rien d'entrer dans la loi
fondamentale une liberté qui n'a rien à
y faire
ici la parole est à Madame billon
merci monsieur le Président alors en
préambule je voudrais dire que tout à
l'heure certains ont voulu opposer des
camps moi je voudrais dire aussi qu'il y
a pas le camp d'un côté des spécialistes
du droit des spécialistes de la
Constitution qui seraient contre la
constitutionnalisation et les autres à
côté qui seraient totalement hors sujets
et qui nous avons nous aussi ceux qui
sont pour la constitutionnalisation et
bien une respiration responsabilité
pleine et entière de l'écriture de la
loi donc moi je remercie notre collègue
Philippe Bas pour cette rédaction de
compromis qui pourrait peut-être nous
rassembler pour avancer sur ce chemin de
la constitutionnalisation du droit à
l'IVG parce que pour moi c'est pas un
symbole pour moi c'est la protection
d'un droit fondamental et je vais bien
entendu voter ce cet amendement cet
amendement de compromis parce que
personne aujourd'hui ne peut garantir
que le droit à l'IVG n'est pas menacé je
peux pas vous dire qu'il est menacé mais
vous pouvez pouvez pas me dire qu'il
n'est pas menacé et donc la passion
d'ailleurs qui a été déchaînée à un
moment dans les débats ce soir et
certains arguments le démontrent donc je
vais voter cet amendement pour garantir
un droit fondamental pour les femmes
dans la Constitution je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Monsieur ravier
merci pour votre monsieur le sénateur
Philippe Bas je suis étonné à plusieurs
égards par votre amendement venant d'un
gaulliste tout d'abord vous souhaitez
participer à l'horizontalisation de la
Constitution dans un texte à verticalité
golienne minant l'intérêt général qui
avait présidé à ces rédactions vous
contribuez à découdre notre contrat
social vous appuyez cette manie
dangereuse d'en faire un self-service
normatif venant dans nos posant aux
inutilités constitutionnelles ensuite
vous disiez en juin 2018 que
l'introduction d'une mention à
l'environnement l'article 1 de la
Constitution n'était je vous cite pas
une question de numérotation car ça ne
changeait rien à ce que dit déjà la
Charte de l'environnement ici aussi ce
n'est pas une question de numérotation
et votre rédaction ne change rien à ce
que dit déjà la loi actuellement en
vigueur venant d'un sénateur attaché au
rôle du Parlement vous choisissez de
nous déposséder un peu plus de notre
pouvoir de décision au profit d'un juge
constitutionnel venant d'un proche
collaborateur de Simone Veil vous
prétendait soutenir l'esprit de sa loi
qui était une dépénalisation en
l'inscrivant sur la clé de voûte de
notre édifice normatif vous assumez de
l'ériger en panacée sociétale enfin
venant d'un élu de droite je crois vous
validez l'initiative d'agide propre et
encore vu aujourd'hui dans les tribunes
vous validez l'initiative d'agit propre
de l'extrême gauche qui ne cherche qu'à
procéder sur le dos de la Constitution
qu'à une OPA une opération politique sur
l'avortement chers collègues à votre
tour ne tombez pas dans ce piège
électoral soyez ferme sur vos
convictions sinon je l'ai déjà dit
jusqu'où irons-nous j'espère que vos
votes d'automne ne se seront pas envolés
avec l'action du vent mauvais venant de
la gauche et que vous serez amené à la
lumière des quelques paradoxes que je
viens de soulever rejeter cette
amendement prélude au rejet du texte
merci monsieur le Président c'est la
parole est au président buffet
monsieur le Président moi je vais
simplement faire juste un petit point
juridique
l'article 37 de la Constitution dans
lequel l'amendement de notre collègue
est présenté
qui a 34 pardon
peut faire durer madame Rossignol avec
beaucoup de plaisir
j'ai la possibilité de le faire c'est
pas mon objectif mais je peux le faire
si vous le souhaitez
il y a aucune difficulté
d'ailleurs je vais discuter un peu avec
quelques collègues en attendant
je disais donc que l'article 34 37
pardon
à une vocation première
qui est de répartir
à la fois le pouvoir de l'exécutif et le
pouvoir législatif c'est sa seule
vocation
il est le résultat du fait que sur la
Quatrième République
les pouvoirs n'étaient pas clairs
l'instabilité était présente et que le
constituant de 58 a voulu clarifier les
choses
ce qui fait que l'inscription de cet
amendement à cet endroit là ne changera
rien
son effet juridique il n'y aura pas en
tous les cas l'effet juridique que vous
souhaitez puisque c'est la chose
prudence du Conseil constitutionnel qui
continuera de s'appliquer c'est
simplement ce que je voulais dire pour
que chacun ait bien conscience des
enjeux
voilà merci
monsieur Delhaize
merci monsieur le Président j'avoue que
je suis un peu resté sur ma faim si je
fais un film exprimer sur la position du
garde des sceaux
qui représente je crois ici le
gouvernement on aurait été content de
savoir ce que comptait faire le
gouvernement
si l'amendement de Monsieur bas était
adopté ou si d'ailleurs il n'était pas
adopté et que le texte initial était
adopté
parce que nous avons été un certain
nombre à vos questionner sur les
intentions et le calendrier si c'était
opportun d'organiser un référendum dans
le contexte actuel et vous nous avez pas
répondu je le regrette parce que ça
mériterait un exercice ment tout ça en
tous les cas certains nombre de
collègues seraient content de savoir ce
que compte faire le gouvernement avec
cette affaire au-delà de nous dire que
vous soutenez on aimerait savoir comment
vous allez soutenir puis la deuxième
observation que je voulais faire c'est
que
malgré tout le respect que je porte à
notre collègue Philippe Bas qui est un
fin juriste j'avoue que j'ai du mal à
voir l'apport dans la constitution de la
formule qui consiste à dire la loi
détermine les conditions dans lesquelles
s'exerce la liberté de mettre fin à sa
grossesse c'est déjà le cas donc
qu'est-ce que ça apporte de plus sinon
d'introduire un article supplémentaire
et le terme
non pas d'IVG mais de fin de grossesse
donc je pense qu'il faut dire les choses
en vérité la proposition de Philippe ne
change rien d'ailleurs il le reconnaît
lui-même donc je ne vois pas l'intérêt
d'aller changer quelque chose qui ne
change rien
allez madame Stach boyaux
alors oui non déplaise à certaines ou à
certains je vais reprendre la parole
parce que je suis extrêmement triste de
la nature de débats qui ont lieu ici on
est d'abord un texte sur la constitution
de l'IVG puis en fait on a un débat de
fond sur l'IVG parce qu'on veut
absolument nous entraîner dans un
discours qui consiste à dire il y a les
Gentils qui sont polivés et puis de
l'autre côté il y a les méchants qui
sont contre les végés ce n'est pas le
débat d'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le
débat d'aujourd'hui et je suis désolé
moi je fais partie d'une génération qui
dit merci à Simone Veil et j'ai pas de
le soir à se voir d'un camp quel qu'il
soit quel qu'il soit nous avons tous eu
nos combats nous avons tous eu nos
engagements et aujourd'hui l'IVG
personne ne le remet en cause personne
on veut nous emmener vers une discussion
qui n'est pas celle de ce texte de loi
et je suis désolé de dire à certains des
collègues ce n'est pas digne du Sénat
allez dernière orateur inscrit monsieur
Loïc Hervé à moins que d'autres oui
encore et plus même
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
j'entends les le débat sur
des personnes qui seraient des
spécialistes de la Constitution d'autres
qui ne le sauraient pas moi en règle
générale je doute avant de décider et je
n'ai aucune certitude
et ce débat me depuis le début
d'ailleurs depuis me faire réfléchir et
me fait cheminer ce dont je suis sûr
c'est que la rédaction constitutionnelle
qu'on doit choisir
si c'est le choix du du législateur
constitutionnel souverain ou si c'est
chaud du peuple si demain le président
de la République convoquait un
référendum chaque mot doit être pesé au
trébuchet on en est à 4 rédactions il y
a même plus le il y a même plus la
référence à l'IVG explicite dans
l'amendement de Philippe Bas imputé à
l'article 34 c'est vous dire le fait que
certains d'entre nous veulent tellement
qui est une référence à l'interruption
moteur de grossesse dans la Constitution
qui sont prêts en accepter n'importe
quelle rédaction
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle ce
4 cette quatrième rédaction qui a été
présentée par une rédaction de compromis
j'aimerais savoir entre qui et qui
bah oui un compromis c'est entre des
personnes qui ont des avis différents
donc si la rédaction du Kester Philippe
Bas et d'une rédaction de compromis
j'aimerais savoir entre qui et qui on en
est à 4 rédactions et je pense que cette
quatrième rédaction qui ne parle même
plus de l'interruption vendeur de
grossesse pose une vraie difficulté donc
je voudrais compte puisque si la maman
de Philippe Bas est adopté
l'article est à nouveau rédigé et ça
emporte adoption de la proposition de
loi si j'ai bien compris ce président ce
serait peut-être pas mal de le rappeler
avant le vote
un dernier orateur pour de bon le
président Retailleau
trois remarques très rapidement la
première c'est que je veux dire à tous
nos collègues que si l'amendement de
Philippe est adoptée ils vaudra adoption
de l'ensemble de la PPL je me rends
compte que tous ne sont pas informés de
cette conséquence juridique deuxième
élément gardez ce à des doutes j'ai une
certitude ça a été dit à plusieurs
reprises la maman de Philippe Bas et
superfétatoire sinon dans cette hémicie
comment aurions pu à plusieurs reprises
débattre de textes de PPL justement qui
avait cette portée sur l'IVG et enfin je
ne vois strictement aucune raison de
modifier le vote que nous avons déjà
émis à l'automne dernier aucune raison
d'un revirement je pense qu'au politique
la constance la cohérence sont des
vertus je pense que j'ai entendu le mot
signal le mot symbolique je pense que la
politique doit être reliée d'abord au
réel et méfions-nous mes chers collègues
parce que à force de déconnecter la
politique du les Français se
déconnecteront ensuite de la politique
merci
je ne vais mettre au voie l'amendement
de rédaction globale de l'article unique
constituant l'ensemble de la proposition
de loi
en application de l'article 59 du
règlement le scrutin public et de droit
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement
le scrutin est ouvert
demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
plus tard
votant 341
exprimé 318 pour 166 contre 152
l'amendement est adopté
de loi est donc adopter
[Musique]
en fonction des 25 années d'assurance
les plus avantageuses la séance est
suspendue